Straightening because nothing works
properly.
There are no good mobile phones.
One,
boom miles only been here for five
minutes.
We've already discussed cocaine,
radical feminism,
a radical progressive's that want to
take over the world.
Uh,
prescription drugs,
tight shirts.
We've gone the full gamut.
We have,
we really have,
and it's,
it's fresh.
It's young and fresh.
We've already gone the full gamut.
Um,
I found out about you,
uh,
I guess it was so many,
just,
I,
I get a lot of interesting stuff tweeted
at me and,
uh,
I read one of your Breitbart pieces and
I was like,
check this motherfucker out.
And then I found out that you're gay and
you're,
you're a part of this gamer gate,
but you're in the game.
You're on this,
you were on the side of the people that
were,
uh,
not the ultra progressive's like,
and then you were in these debates
against these radical feminism chicks
and shutting them down.
And I was like,
you were very kind about me.
Play some video.
Look at this motherfucker.
You're a unicorn.
Like they don't like people like you.
I'm not supposed to exist into the
progressive rules of the universe.
I should not be.
Yeah,
you should.
You're not supposed to be like fairly
buttoned down and conservative and,
and fare well also factually correct.
Like all the stuff that you would,
the thing that I'd seen,
you've gotten in his argument about why
certain women gravitate towards certain
jobs and men gravitate towards jobs and
this idea that,
that a lot of this is just cultural.
A lot of this is something that we're
pushing upon young men and young women
and you were like,
well,
this isn't the case at all.
They're just hilarious to watch someone
confronted by.
Like they expect that to come from a me.
They expected to come from some
[inaudible] like I ought to be
supporting the exact and on paper like
paper,
I should,
you know what I mean?
I'm a metropolitan.
Yeah.
I'm,
since I would be a liberal,
I'm a homosexual.
I listen.
I'd like pop culture,
you know,
all of those things.
I shouldn't really exist,
but I do
for that one 10th of your tweets are
about how fabulous your hair is.
Yeah.
So black,
Greek,
you know,
I of those things,
any of those subjects,
you know,
his hair or you know,
the men that I'm into,
it's very,
very difficult for them to beat me for
one simple reason,
which is they've never been questioned.
I've never been called in any of this
stuff by anybody's serious or anybody
who's a,
who doesn't conform to the progressive
rules if identity politics.
So when they come from me,
they usual the usual response from a
feminist to anybody bringing facts or
accountants as serious counter argument
is simply to dismiss them as a sexist or
a bigot or a misogynist.
It's really tough to make the allegation
against me.
I love women.
All my friends are women.
I don't have any,
I don't have a dog in the fight sexually
speaking.
I don't care if I don't,
I don't want to bang them,
whatever size they are,
however they behave.
So they really don't,
they don't have that over me.
It's very,
very difficult to come up against the
guy that you cannot make a convincing
argument,
uh,
of bigotry again.
So you have to argue on the facts.
And of course the facts are on my side.
Well that's what the deal is.
They dismiss
you instantaneously because of what you
represent because what you represented
like,
well look,
we got the dirt on him.
He's,
he's,
he's gay and he's fabulous shit,
what are we going to do?
But once you start,
once you start to hit their radar,
you note that you get calls from friends
who say said this,
this person I emailed me trying to check
you out.
This happened to me about a year ago.
So I sort of hit an a journalist for 10
years.
What are some good staff?
Brooklyn's a big stories,
but I never really,
I never really kind of crossed over into
entertainment into the mainstream and
just started to happen about year ago
and I started to get emails from friends
and they were saying,
I'm so what?
What's going on here?
People keep emailing me,
asking me about you like trying to ask
like in back in 2011 did he really do
this?
And what I've realized is when they,
when they recognize you as a threat,
when they identify you as somebody could
do them damage,
they start going on maneuvers,
trying to find out everything about
your,
trying to find out what the worst stuff
they have on you is so that he can
dismiss you as a bigot or a sexist or a
Neo Nazi or whatever.
They can come up with anything.
They can grasp that because their
strategy is to dismiss the,
is to dismiss the speaker by attacking
the speakers credibility.
Because that way they never have to even
consider the merits of the argument.
They haven't been able to do that with
me.
Um,
which is why feminists now refuse to
beat me up,
debate me on TV because they know
they'll lose.
Um,
they can't bring out all,
they can't bring out,
they've got this battery of dismissing
their dismissal tactics that they've
amassed over the last 30 years and
they've got so complacent because
they've never had,
you know,
a Sassy gay person and come up and say
it.
You're talking bullshit and you're
hurting men and here are the facts.
They've never had it before,
so they've never built up on arsenal to
fight it.
Um,
you know,
so this is,
this is why I went and while Cook I'll
keep winning because they don't really
know how to deal with an argument on its
own merits.
And in any case,
of course,
the fact that we're on our so
well,
it's also this conversation that we're
having right now is about war.
You're saying winning and losing and
they're taking tactics and strategies to
look up dirt on the opposition.
They're going,
they're treating.
This is it.
This is an ideological war is not a
debate about the facts of the issue.
And I think that's part of it because
the left has always seen this as a war.
And the gender warriors,
you know,
have always been warriors.
They've always seen this in strategic
terms.
I'm not sure people on conservatives and
naturally more self effacing
conservatives tend to be a little bit
cool,
a little bit more chill about things.
They kind of don't
do you really draw it though?
How do you explain tape?
I think they get very angry about
things.
Explain Ted Cruz,
what am I saying?
Old Conservatives,
but he explained,
uh,
what's her name?
The Pailin chick.
Sarah Palin.
How to explain that.
These are the,
these are the outline is that Mike
Huckabee,
even most conservatives find these
people a bit much.
My car could be,
I think that guy's in isn't in the end.
Who knows how these cells fatter now he
was hopping around last time.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
for like the lazy got that cushion TV
gigs so far he got so far I cannot vote
for anyone.
That phenomenon of rock and rolling.
I Want Marco Rubio just because he's
hot.
You know,
if we call have Trump than I won't
regret it.
I don't think,
I think people are silly.
So whether or not it's a conservative
thing or a liberal thing,
I think there's a vast majority of
people that aren't not
very good at looking at themselves and
they're not very good at looking at the
momentum of their actions.
They just think that they're right
because this is what they've been saying
for so long.
And I think that's one of the most
horrific things about these
conversations with these women.
Get in with you about cause like when,
when they're talking about what they
think are social constructs,
things like gender identities and the
way people be.
And when you shatter that with the
facts,
they're looking for some other weapons
and there's nothing there and you see it
in their eyes.
You know,
cause it's not really a debate about the
idea itself.
It's just not what,
it's not what it's about is gender will
fat.
That's why people like Christina Hoff
summers cold them gender warriors
because these aren't people who want any
kind of social justice as they say.
These are people who just hate men.
Well,
there's hate men.
They want to hurt men.
Um,
they don't want to quality for women.
They want to,
they want superiority for women,
whether it's architected into the
education system or you know,
affirmative action or whatever it is.
They don't want quality.
They want superiority.
And fundamentally,
a lot of this,
you know,
these,
these crazy extremist,
you know,
uh,
progressive third wave feminists,
today's version of feminism.
It basically boils down to messenger and
it takes a gay guy because it's so
dangerous for men to even broach this
subject anymore.
And any man with a mainstream job puts
that at risk by even talking on the
subject no matter what his opinion is.
Um,
it takes a gay guy to go on,
you know,
Sky News in the UK and say,
I'm sorry,
the facts are not on your side and what
you're doing is damaging to women.
Um,
it's to me really an indictment on a,
on debate in our public square that it
is so dangerous for a man to even
express an opinion on this subject,
that it takes a fact they're going to
stick up for heterosexuals.
And you know,
if other men could say this,
they would be,
but they can't because they would run
the risk of their careers.
What feminists always talking about
silencing people icy silence to men.
Well that,
that is true.
There's a lot of doxing and going after
people and a lot of,
a lot of anger when it comes to all this
stuff.
But I think what you have in many cases
when you see this kind of like
disjointed,
illogical sort of way of thinking,
I think you have people that are
assholes that find a cause that gives
him the green light to be an asshole.
Well,
I've written about this,
you know,
I agree with you.
I think,
no disrespect to any particular church,
but I think it's reasonable to say 50
years ago if you were a bully,
if you are a sociopath,
do you want us to take out in other
people?
You want it to Rick harm on the world
that you thought would hurt you?
Reasonably good way of doing that would
be to join the clergy and many and many
people did.
And I think most of us who are
religious,
who have religious families know stories
like that.
These days,
you're better off getting a job at
Gorka.
Um,
you know,
if you want to bully somebody,
if you really want to hurt them,
if you have some sort of internal chaos
or damage and you want to impose order
on the world outside because you feel so
confused and broken and messy,
uh,
the best way to do it today,
it's become a social justice warrior.
Because not only do you get the same
kind of status in society the clergy
would have done 50 years ago,
but you also get media platforms.
You get money,
you get approval,
you get applause.
And if you layer on these new tactics
of,
you know,
fake abuse and fake Harrison,
and you know,
these terrible man,
you know,
these terrible men coming for me on the
Internet,
see if you can make quite a lot
of money too.
Yeah,
you can form a patrion page and then
people just sending the audio.
What is that?
It's like,
it's like a crowd fund me for my ideas.
Right?
So in the,
in the old days you'd have patrons of
the arts and there would be,
you know,
like a prince or some rich guy or maybe
the,
uh,
maybe a little later in history it would
be a mercantile patron.
And in the way,
in the way that,
um,
many industrialists and bankers still
give a lot of money to their local opera
house or something like that.
So patch on is a way of turning that
open into crowdfunding.
So your,
your patron becomes a load of people,
all of whom give you a little bit of
money.
Right.
So it's,
it's in theory quite a respectable and
interesting way of funding the outs.
In principle,
there's nothing wrong with it,
but it seems to become colonized by
people who are raising money on the
basis of sympathy rather than anything
they actually create.
So it's what I've,
what I've noticed in my reporting on
this is the vast majority of people
begging for money on Pantry on as far as
I can tell,
I'm sure Patrick and will tell me,
you know,
most of them went on their platform,
goes creative projects.
But as far as I can tell,
it's,
you know,
people bleating for sympathy,
fishing for empathy.
It's a,
there's a lot of women on there claiming
to be,
you know,
claiming that their lives are being
ruined by manual.
Actually look into it.
I can't find the tweets are talking
about,
um,
you know,
and it's,
and it's a way for,
there's this,
there's this great tweet by,
um,
what's an airport who is ochre gamergate
supporter.
And I can't,
I'm going to remember it wrongly,
but it's something along the lines of,
you know,
every day on the Internet,
some goonie beard man,
uh,
you know,
promises to be nice to a social justice
warrior in the hope of a wink or the
hope of a blow job or something like
that.
You know,
and it's,
it's these guys who were just sort of
throw a fiver or throw a tenner a month,
you know,
$20 a month to this video games
developer who's never produced anything
in her life,
but claims she's getting harassed and
claims are getting threats.
It's very,
very weird,
um,
psychological dynamic.
And I think it's,
I think it's quite,
it's,
it's interwoven with the way that
feminism has turned women into
professional victims,
handed them this victim hood script.
And most of these women are not really
to blame.
They're not kind of,
these aren't,
these aren't horrible sociopathic,
you know?
Warmongers these aren't people who
really hate man.
They're just a bit miserable and they've
reached for the nearest victim hood
script available to them because we live
in a culture where,
you know,
a victim hood is the,
is the most valuable currency that you
can,
um,
but you can amass.
And,
um,
and so they go out,
they advertise what a terrible life they
have and how awful people ask them on
the Internet.
And they ask men,
mainly it's women asking for money from
men.
Um,
you know,
effectively for sympathy dollars.
It's incredibly demeaning.
It's incredibly,
you know,
to the human spirit,
aside from anything else,
you know,
you're basically telling these women
that they have more value as winches and
liars and gender warriors than they do
as creators or mothers.
Um,
and I find that hugely destructive.
I think that what we're,
we're,
we're talking about as far as like
people that are assholes that just
launch off,
latch onto a cause.
And then that if you go to their page,
like there's,
there's so many of them that write and
you'd go
to their blog and their blog is just an
attack blog.
Yeah.
It's just consistent attacks on people
that don't share their ideas or don't or
have differing ideas of coined a term
for this.
What is it?
I've coined sentence quantum superstate
feminism and it is an,
it is feminism that exists at once as
aggressor and victim.
It is simultaneously and at all times
And it's describes these women who go
out lobbing shit at people,
uh,
and then instantly turned into damsels
in distress when they,
when they see their own language
returned in kind,
you know,
quite often returned at greater volume
because what they're saying is
ridiculous and offensive and people get
annoyed about it perfectly.
Reasonably.
And also,
if you create an environment in which
it's fine to say anything you want about
man,
it's fine to say kill white men.
It's fine to publish articles in,
you know,
in,
in mainstream news media publications
about how to hurt man and all the rest
of it.
Just sort of several years ago,
who was just the woman recently,
the Google ideas woman that had the
tweet about,
uh,
she eats men for breakfast.
This is,
I think he's talking about Randy Harper.
If you imagine if a guy wrote that down,
I eat women for Breck.
What unit?
Do you know?
Some men do speak to women like that?
Some of the men's rights activists on
Twitter?
Well,
yes,
but do you know why men's rights
activists are so rude to women because
they're assholes?
Well,
know what they're doing.
It women have for 30 years said,
treat us like men were just like,
man,
we're just the same.
Treat us like men.
We can do anything that men can do.
You can do everything that men can do.
Men's rights activists just take them at
their word and the weight and taunting
is how many bombs,
you know,
that's not what they're doing,
how they're doing.
And they're not trying to bond with
these women.
They're trying to hurt them.
Well I think what they're doing is
taking it,
taking it at face value,
this demand for,
for us to treat women.
I see us for them to treat women.
Um,
you know,
uh,
just just like they would their buddies
down the pub.
Well if you ever actually been to a pub
when you were hearing men like
outplaying pain sneaker or whatever,
their fucking awful to each other.
But I think they're doing exactly the
same thing.
They don't want these women doing.
Everyone's just being a cunt.
They just like take away the gender.
It's a,
men are being conscious,
women are being cons.
People are reaching through these
internet lines turn to hurt each other.
That's what they're doing.
I think it's true and I'm not,
I'm not totally on board with a whole
men,
men in [inaudible] men's rights for a
second.
I think anybody who spends so much time
working on their like approval of their
own gender,
like w w we're supporting our own
gender.
Like there's a lot of dudes that are
pieces of shit.
There's a lot of women that are
assholes.
It's just,
I think part of the problem is that they
sort of become feminists in reverse and
they use the same tactics.
They like to show large police.
They also,
I mean it's amazing.
You go on some of these communities in
Reddit and you read some of these blogs
and they're sort of,
you know,
they're like fainting couch men's rights
activists.
You know,
if I have a friend Julie Bentall,
who's very,
very funny,
she's a lesbian,
she's,
yeah,
she's basically this dike feminist.
She hates men.
She made this joke and it's kind of like
the sort of joke I would make.
She said,
you know,
we should put all men and internment
camps.
You know,
they could,
they can have visitation once a month,
we'll have guards and they could just
stay in camps until they learn how to
behave.
If I'd said that about women,
the whole is fear as it were,
would be like applauding.
They think it was hilarious,
but because she said it in a similar
level of jest,
you know,
suddenly it was just disgusting,
outrageous thing.
You know,
feminists has,
men should be put in concentration
camps.
And I was like,
bitches really?
Are you fucking kidding me?
This is exactly what feminists do.
You are taking a joke like it,
you're taking a joke,
you're pretending to take it seriously,
and then you're starting an outrage
circus about it.
And I was like,
for fuck's sake,
I am out.
It's recreational outrage.
It is what it is.
Isn't that,
isn't that what this is supposed to be
like fighting against,
you know,
I'm in this because I'm like a cultural
libertarian as my colleague Alan Bakari
puts it.
Um,
you know,
I believe in classical liberalism,
freedom of speech,
freedom of thought,
freedom of expression.
You know,
I don't care what you believe,
I just want you to have,
I want,
I want to be able to interrogate your
ideas in the public square.
Um,
but yeah,
this outrage circus that so many men
seem to be getting involved in and the
way they treat,
you know,
they call,
they call circumcision male genital
mutilation.
And I'm like,
wait a minute,
isn't it?
You're,
you're coming,
you're,
uh,
you're one of those,
but no,
I'm just saying,
I mean,
it is,
look,
I'm going to write it's cutting skin
while I'm in favor of it purely on
aesthetic grounds.
I understand that these things in my
mouth.
Okay.
I can understand from your point of
view,
I can understand that your
baby should be able to make a decision
on later in life.
No,
no.
I,
I haven't,
but if you have a view,
I know lots of men don't like on this
issue and it's simply that,
you know,
it's just good grooming.
Frankly.
Women,
women go on,
women go onto,
I'm serious.
Women go on to the ninth.
I have boob jobs and all the rest of it.
Why stop penises?
Attractive,
sexy procedure that comes close to the
numbers of babies that gets circumcised.
That's done.
The female girl,
one of these people.
I mean,
I just
like birth as they're just weird,
but I think I'm in the minority here.
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry to offend you,
but I think I'm in the minority here,
but I just can't imagine why any man
wouldn't want lots and lots of really
good blow jobs because,
well,
apparently it feels better when the skin
is on or no,
no,
it's so much.
How do you know unless you've done both?
What?
Because I've got feedback from,
I've,
I've a,
it's all anecdotal evidence this way
off.
I've got a large sample size.
You just liked the way they look better
when it's all trimmed up nice.
Every other woman,
which is telling you to choice based a
lot on what we're used to having it done
later in life.
It's not nice if you're fucking dumb
enough to get your Dick's getting cut
off when you're 30 I hope.
I hope it hurts the camaraderie on this.
You don't have to suck one of these
things.
Okay.
That's all I'm going to say.
We should leave it there.
I wouldn't have liked to believe that I
have the same approach that I do to
vaginas.
Like if a girl at a big vagina lips,
I wouldn't say d.
You know,
he shouldn't have kept that shit cut
off.
I think bit what it looks now.
It's horrifying.
No,
we'll leave it there.
That's what it is.
It is what it is.
Big nipples like,
do you gonna get them shrunk down?
That's fucking barbaric.
I don't know about the mind,
you know?
Well,
it's interesting.
No,
I mean I there it,
you know,
there people aren't scrupulously cutting
babies.
Dick's is stupid.
God Sake.
It's a baby's Dick.
You don't have to cut his deck.
I mean,
you know how many kids lose their dicks
every year because of infections and
because of the surgery goes wrong?
A lot can't win.
If you're going to take this view,
if you're going to take this line like
cutting babies,
Dick's,
I can't win.
I can't win against that one's
a surgical procedure.
I'm happy to be in the minority on this
one.
Pleasing surgical procedure.
You know what?
All you might be cutting all you
motherfuckers out there.
He would want to keep you full scan.
Right?
I'm going to,
I'm going to get,
I'm going to give these world class blow
jobs to the juice instead.
Congratulations on your worldclass blow
jobs.
My favorite story was my least favorite
story,
but when my favorite story to bring up
was oil in New York who had herpes and
when they,
when they cut the baby's Dick in the
traditional way,
they actually suck on the baby's penis
to stop the bleeding.
Have you ever seen this?
I've ever heard articles about this.
Yes,
I have.
Yes.
And the kid died cause a,
the kid got herpes from the rabbi,
the oil,
whatever the fuck his name is.
What a great idea.
Cut and baby dicks could have grown up
to solve cancer or one of those things.
Either one of them can be awesome.
Meanwhile,
nope.
Dead Baby.
Well,
I don't think anyone's going to disagree
with you on that particular incident.
Don't cut baby dicks,
but they'll have the fuck did we get on?
I don't know.
But it was inevitable.
I mean,
you know,
look,
there's absolutely a bunch of horrible
shit that happens to women on a daily
basis.
I mean,
every time you see these fucking Cosby
stories,
these women that are coming out of
nowhere about bill Cosby,
when,
when women talk about worrying about
being drugged,
and if you don't know anybody that's
actually happened to,
or someone close to you that's actually
happened to,
that danger doesn't seem real.
So when you,
but you see this bill Cosby thing and
you're like,
not only is it real,
it's like,
here's the guy that was America's,
his voice,
the voice of Morality for a generation.
Um,
this becomes such a mania,
a moral panic,
like a moral panics in history about
this stuff that the genuine victims are
starting to,
to be disbelieved.
And this is driven by,
I'm sorry to say,
kind of the sort of progressive
narrative over fat kind of journalism.
Sabrina Erdely and rolling stone and all
these rapes we hear about,
they all seem to unravel within a couple
of months.
Is that was the rolling stone was Uva.
Yeah.
Which didn't have the virtuous girl at
Columbia didn't happen.
A Jute Lacrosse didn't happen.
Yeah.
You know,
all these things have happened.
Well,
yes,
but we should,
we should
be.
We should be working at how to solve and
prevent these crimes better.
And the waste you that is not to erect.
It is not to stage a moral panic in the
media,
um,
pointing fingers at innocent people.
And when you see,
when you as was clearly the case with
rolling stone,
sort of sweep under the carpet facts or
omissions that,
that,
that doubt on your story because you
think this is just something we should
be talking about anyway.
Whether this specific case,
whether we have the details right,
this specific case,
what happens is when all of it,
when these rape stories or whatever it
is,
um,
get ripped,
get,
uh,
success is successive rape stories get
repudiated and debunked.
It undermines confidence and trust in
anyone who makes that complaint.
Anyone who says this happened to me
right in the back of their head.
I think perfectly reasonably,
people are thinking,
oh man,
another one.
Um,
you know,
it's not a nice thing,
but this is what this is.
This can be the effect of a moral panic
in the media.
It,
it damages the real victims,
um,
the most.
And that's,
you know,
that's why I've written about this stuff
in the past.
I think it's also why it's really
important to tell the truth about
statistics.
Now,
feminists are always have a,
they have a complicated relationship
with the truth.
Um,
one is the one in four week.
Exactly.
I mean this goes all the way up to
Obama.
Every time you hear it seems to get
worse,
you know,
but I think we extrapolate out it's
going to be like 50 women in five gets
raped within a second of stepping on
campus by 2025.
Um,
you know,
it gets worse every time.
It's based on ridiculous studies.
I mean the,
the way I started I think Christina Hoff
Summers at the American Enterprise
Institute who I was site cause she's so
fantastic.
Um,
and so when other Unicorn,
so on point of March is feminist
feminist lever and she,
you know,
she just had some problems with um,
with contemporary feminism and gender
warriors.
Um,
you know,
she,
she does a great series of the factual
feminist.
I'm sure a lot of your viewers are
already,
um,
but,
uh,
you know,
she,
she sort of tracked down the original
study for this,
which was,
you know,
samples has about 70 people and an adult
education college,
which is so eight to so completely alien
in character.
I mean,
these people are like 20 years older,
you know,
and of course there's,
adult education cultures,
you know,
there,
there are different,
there is a different set of social
issues that go along with adult
education college then,
then 20 year olds Undergrad,
you know,
what do you call them?
Freshmen,
uh,
you know,
[inaudible] doing a regular degree in
college.
I'm sample size was ridiculous.
The university was atypical and this has
been extrapolated out to this,
to this feminist myth that just won't
die.
Like,
but like the gender pay gap as well,
how they define like,
there's people that want definition
sexually,
but there's actually a section of sexual
assault and sexual abuse has been
broadened so widely.
What's getting crazy regret in some
universities?
Um,
it is part of the university's conduct
code that unwanted sexual advances.
That means me saying,
you're really pretty,
can I buy you a drink?
Constitutes sexual harassment.
Now this is just,
you know,
you're gonna have to close down every
nightclub in the country.
Um,
it's just extraordinary bonkers.
you know,
crazy stuff.
And this is,
you know,
30 years unchallenged feminism,
which is why I do what I do,
because I think it matters.
I think it's important.
I talked to Guy,
he's 20 years old,
you know,
our age,
right?
Um,
I don't know how old you are,
I guess,
you know,
you're 48.
Okay,
fine.
So I mean,
like,
you know,
you're,
you're maybe my dad's almost at my dad's
generation,
but anyone your age,
even right down to my age,
I'm 30.
It would have been a bit ridiculous for
us to say that,
you know,
society is architected against men.
You know,
when we were growing up,
it just wasn't the case.
And there's no point trying to pretend
that it was.
But I speak to boys all the time and
I've interviewed,
you know,
so many of them now have about 20,
who do go through life experiencing this
extraordinary,
um,
uh,
sort of,
architecture,
you know,
against them,
whether it's being,
you know,
wax on Adderall at school or more women,
getting into university for no good
reason or women as in a Cornell to 2015
studies show that women have to two to
one advantage going for a stem job in
academia.
Um,
so being discriminated against because
they don't have a vagina.
Um,
20 year old boys do have some serious
problems now.
Um,
and we,
you know,
we risk not just one,
but many lost generations of boys.
I call this this exodus or a big
two-parter about this that I think,
I think a lot of people were very nice
about,
um,
seem to go down very well.
Um,
yeah,
there's some really serious stuff to
address,
which is why I do one of the reasons I
do what I do because I,
you know,
I think that's what journalism is
supposed to be for.
You know,
speaking up for,
for people who don't have a platform
themselves and for,
um,
you know,
so the,
the establishment has lost,
uh,
lost sight of and it doesn't care about
anymore.
That's why I think it's important to
tell the truth about statistics.
You can't help victims if you lie,
but in your first sentence about what
the problem is and there is not a,
you know,
a systemic problematic gender pay gap in
the United States or in Europe.
There is not a,
um,
uh,
an epidemic of rape culture on campus.
There is not,
you know,
a problem in universities or,
uh,
with not enough women going into stem
into science,
technology or mathematics subjects.
All of these things are so subtle and
sophisticated explanations that,
you know,
when you were taken to account human
nature and the different choices people
make and what women want to do,
um,
you realize that this stuff is bunk,
but many of these myths simply won't
die.
Well,
you also have to take into consideration
there's a bunch of other variables,
right?
Like women leaving because they have
children and you have to factor that in
to the amount of income you can generate
gap.
This stuff,
this stuff is based on a
misunderstanding between earnings and
pay.
You can't take all the men in society
and all the,
we're going to get in society and do
like a two,
two stage calculation and said,
right,
well there's 77% as much money on this
side.
Right?
Right.
That's not what people mean when they
say there's a page where you say that
it's the way you tell it to say
something.
There's a wage gap.
What what they think you mean is women
get paid 77 cents on the dollar.
Do you know if that's the phrase they
use to a man's right,
implying that women get paid less for
the same work.
That's the implication that they're
making through all of this cause they're
confusing earnings with wages,
right?
Um,
earnings with pay.
What actually happens is men work longer
hours.
Men take,
even when you control for children,
men take fewer,
fewer holidays.
They take shorter holidays,
they work longer hours,
they make more money for their firms.
All the rest of it may just work harder.
Um,
they have longer careers,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
women prefer whether or not they have
children to have a more balanced life.
They prefer not to work full time that I
have to work part time.
They,
you know,
have more of a rash generalizations
because of course it was on both sides.
We all know lazy,
Lazy,
this is the way the left dog or is that
not all women are giving me a break,
you know,
but you know what I'm saying,
but speak in generalizations if you've
got to communicate how to do that
because you know,
there are,
I mean I think the term is to test
Stickley.
There are more men that are working
longer hours that are working harder,
that generate more money.
But to say like,
men do that well,
we all know lazy fucks it just with the
man we do
it.
Is that,
um,
the reason I phrase it exactly like that
is that I don't want to,
you know,
let's not open up the,
this whole,
not all men stuff that the left and
right,
because that's the,
that's that's the,
that's the,
um,
that is the route into this sort of
social conditioning argument.
Yeah.
Just objective.
Well,
what I'm trying to,
what the point I'm trying to make is
that men,
generally men,
men generally have the following traits,
right.
And this is reflected in employment and
you have those traits.
But I mean,
you know,
we've got to come to the lazy lazy men.
Uh,
yeah,
sure.
I'm there.
There are some lazy men,
but there were also men dropping out of
society because of,
you know,
because,
uh,
they feel that there's just no place for
them anymore.
You know,
they've had their,
what they consider to be their role in
the family,
um,
snatched away from them that I'll was
the last two generations real issue.
Yeah.
Well,
again,
I think your generation is,
my generation sounds ridiculous,
but I speak to 20 year old boys all the
time who are saying,
I can't be bothered with women.
You know,
there's this movement and midtown men
going their own way.
They're,
they're actually,
she fuck is involved.
Will you say that?
But there's a lot of guys know you say
that 10 years,
10 years ago we took about five days
later,
10 years,
10 years ago.
Uh,
sure.
But today the numbers are below the
blossoming,
that blossoming.
It was so fast.
And you know,
the thing is men deal reasonably well
without women.
They don't like to do it.
Look,
people who people like us are not going
to want for sex,
right?
Um,
because we're outgoing and ballsy and
brash and self confident,
all the rest of it,
right?
Uh,
we're not going to have it too much of a
problem,
but there are plenty of men who don't
have our self confidence and who are
being bullied and derided and ridiculed
everyday in the media at this stuff gets
you people get depressed about this
stuff.
This is the male suicide epidemic.
You know,
this is a huge epidemic across the
board.
No,
that,
well,
the number,
the number of female suicides.
I mean it's different statistics,
different countries.
It's a different slightly,
but you know,
the female numbers aren't really
changing.
Women are getting more unhappy a decade
after decade,
but they don't actually commit suicide.
They never go through with it.
When they try,
they fail.
They can't even commit suicide probably
there four to seven covenant.
They kind of a killed themselves
properly.
They're forcing the men to kill
themselves.
Well,
they often,
well we've women often road,
we went off and write the suicide notes
and then they try to kill themselves and
they fail or they call they or they
bottle it at the last minute and call.
Someone said up taking some pills.
They never,
they never ended up dead.
Uh,
but men just,
you know,
go quiet for a few days and then they
just hang themselves.
Um,
but those,
those numbers are going up.
The number of men who were just giving
up some relationships,
that number is going up.
I can't believe that.
See,
because then you're factoring in you
this kind of like,
you know,
swolled media star where he hangs out
with,
you know,
good looking,
fashionable people all got girlfriends,
you know,
banging,
banging our girls.
Um,
it's not,
it's,
sorry,
I just had a moment then.
Uh,
no,
it's not your womb while married kids.
Yeah,
yeah.
Whatever.
I don't need to know what you get up to.
Um,
but yeah,
I know what you're saying.
This is not the case.
There's going to be no,
no,
it's not some unhappy people.
This is not just cancer filings of men
out there by themselves just alone.
Just giving up.
You should,
uh,
you should pay more attention.
You should listen to them when they're
speaking to you because they need people
like you.
Come on,
man.
This is a small metal really down to me.
Is it going to be this fucking British
queer who's going to stick up for these
guys when even you won't stick up?
Kick off these
drive out as society,
man,
man's radio host and these guys,
God,
what am I camp outside?
No cell phone.
This is a fucking man.
That's why I have the fucking media
beating down my door.
Because even you guys won't stick up for
men anymore.
You can't just coddle them like that.
If they really want to draw what groups
to hoard with girls.
Dude,
you can.
I'm a total sociopath,
but I still preach a little sympathy on
this issue.
How dare you.
But no,
I'm not.
But um,
women,
the feminist,
we'll call you that.
All right.
Well I think has some terrible thing,
especially where the male feminists,
but trying to get Brownie points.
Oh,
warm honey of the,
the war.
Male feminists
do their Twitter profile and,
but I usually don't write male
feminists.
They're just feminists.
Just feminist.
And I'm like,
Oh God,
how long has it been?
How long does it,
they just want to,
I want to ask them how long has it been?
Like two months.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
How long has it been?
Two years.
That's it.
That's why you're a feminist.
But this is what they don't understand
is the kind of women they're sucking up
to.
Don't even want them.
No.
Women don't want men to speak about
feminists.
If they don't want allies because no man
is ever going to be good enough to speak
about women's issues is the crux of
identity politics.
Modern feminists don't want men,
they hate man.
Stop sucking up to them.
The only way you're going to get them is
to connect them.
to say you are a ridiculous fucking
whore and I'm paying you no attention
whatsoever and that's how you get them.
Well,
it's worked for me.
It works that way.
Okay,
maybe not that language,
but you know you're addicted.
You're ridiculous woman.
I'm paying no attention whatsoever.
And that key second part of the phrase
was what I was really focusing on that
second part of that phrase.
That's what makes him come running.
Being shuttled games like a Turkey.
You got to know her,
right?
No one to make the hand because I don't
have skin in the game.
You see?
So I'm able to analyze these things just
passionately.
Well,
there's some truth to that.
Certainly.
There's definitely some truth to wise
gate uncle,
you know who can just sort of from a
distance can tell you what's it telling
you,
what's going,
what's happening.
It's just pathetic to watch those poor
men grovel.
Grovel for Social Brownie points.
Yes it is.
And they're never going to get the hand
job.
I'll get,
it's not going to happen,
but it's even that they can't see that
it's not about feminism.
It's not about masculinism either,
if that's a word.
It's about people not being full of
Shit,
you know,
not crying victim when you're not really
a victim.
Not pulling the fucking fire alarm on a
Pr Guy who's a that Toronto thing where
the,
the guy was,
they totally misrepresented the position
of his book,
misrepresented what his position was on
women period and on men.
And he was just essentially trying to
highlight,
some men have and they were calling them
just,
they call me.
I quite like getting insults because I'd
like to,
I'd like to rate them.
I get them marks out of 10 and then I
come back to the troll and I explained
how they could've made it better.
How they could improve,
you know,
so I like to take my tape to troll
school.
And you know,
sometimes people send you good things
like go take up off of the toaster,
which is quite funny.
Like,
I like that.
That's a good one.
More people [inaudible] they just didn't
circuit breaker.
Well I liked to joke anyway.
And then sometimes it's just,
you know,
you deserve to die two out of 10,
come on,
you can do better.
Um,
if this is what they do and this is what
they do,
they are,
you know,
the insults and ridicule and demean and
tried to discredit the speaker.
And if they can't do that,
they will do some other kind of
silencing of no platforming and
whatever.
So those opinions can never be,
you know,
they do not want those opinions ever
aired in public because those opinions
and the facts that underpin them,
um,
the reasoning that underpins them,
which is what people go to these talks
to here is so dangerous to feminist
narrative,
which is basically,
you know,
based on,
on feeling and not fact based on,
um,
you know,
bigotry and Kloss and gender hatred,
not any kind of sensible analysis.
The way the world works.
I've got so many invitations to
universities for the next six months,
and you know,
this isn't an advertisement,
20 feminists listening,
but I know this is going to happen.
Um,
and you know,
the talks go on anyway,
it just takes,
takes up a whole day of your life
instead of an afternoon.
But,
you know,
I know it's going to happen.
I've got talk,
I'm,
you know,
I'm going,
I'm speaking at Universum swings at USC
a Republican's next week.
I'm speaking,
um,
you know,
to a bunch of UK and US universities
over the next six months.
And I just know what's coming,
you know,
and it's,
it's this extraordinary like a homeless
gay dude.
You know,
I cracked Dick Jokes on Twitter and I do
Sky News now and again.
And if,
you know,
if I'm,
if I'm like the scariest opponent,
you know,
that they have,
they've got real problems.
Um,
but you are,
because of what we highlighted earlier,
they can't dismiss it is semi joking,
all that shit.
It's like,
you know,
semi joking but I'm not kind of a game
and make your argument for God's sake.
And why is it that for the last 30 years
they have been incapable or unwilling of
actually making an argument and instead
they do everything they can to simply
get the speaker out of the public eye.
Well,
because they exist in an echo chamber.
I mean,
I think that the,
the forums that they go to,
the Twitter groups that they,
I've gone to people's pages cause I find
out they're ridiculous.
I read,
I read an article about this page and
went to his Twitter page and I was
already blocked.
I'd never even interacted with block
lists.
You want a boat,
you're on a block list is probably cause
you following me.
I seem to be,
I seem to like sort of Voldemort for
these guys.
Just had a few controversial things
myself.
It might just be thinking about saying
what's wasn't as controversial thing.
If it was at Tommy fucking,
I will take a long time.
We'd have to get me through the
Internet.
Uh,
what kind of say that?
You're saying if you are,
if you're a man,
you call yourself a feminist.
I hope you choke to death on Vegan
Pizza.
Why crying to a lady Gaga Song is that
she upset with me.
Variable.
Is that controversial?
Yes.
Is it talking about death?
Oh,
okay.
I prefer they get raped with wow.
Male rape is not as bad as female rape
though.
Right.
You could say like male rape to the
pizza.
It doesn't seem as awful.
It's funny,
some of us go out and search with male
rape.
That's a comical thing to say though.
A man being raped by a pizza.
Whereas if a woman gets raped by pizza,
it's just funny.
It's just so nuts.
Not well.
You see hard to,
I'll tell you what,
I liked it.
I liked that.
I liked that you find it horrible
because it shows to me that chivalry is
not dead and you have a decent respect
for,
you know,
for women and for speaking about women
properly.
And I like that you're offended by what
offended because I like that you find it
distasteful to speak of women in that
way because it speaks well of you.
Um,
I think what feminism is done,
I think what feminism has done is made
it very difficult to be nice about women
because the critic,
this environment where there's so much
hate and bile and ridiculed men,
men feel like they've got to respond in
kind or just check out entirely and
it's,
it's this,
that's what I don't buy.
I think you have a very small minority
are not very attractive who get really
upset at men.
And I have a theory about sociological
shit when it comes to these really
radical anti male feminists.
A lot of it is a constant state of
rejection,
but these disproportionate effect,
what's on these,
these ugly women who,
by the way,
there are all sorts of studies which I
love,
which show the ugly women are much more
likely to be liberals.
Um,
and of course they make sense for all
the reasons you would imagine.
Um,
so they find feminism or perhaps they
start losing their looks in their
thirties.
So they did.
They,
um,
you know,
slide back into feminism.
Yeah,
no,
women are gone at 30 on that.
I,
I'm,
I like,
I like sex.
I'm the tip of gates that take,
you know,
all my eight 30 and I like to start
requesting things in their forties.
A lot of times they'll leave and go to
yoga,
but what the statistics show is that,
um,
women,
uh,
in their thirties,
if they're still single stock a bit
nuts,
they report themselves as being
generally more unhappy with life,
more likely to have contemplated
suicide,
like pressed,
uh,
men considered retreat into point of
video games.
But women get women,
women go nuts if they're single in their
thirties.
So thanks.
Feminism,
right?
So it's all women.
You see,
you,
you don't know you it so much ground
already by allowing yourself to be taken
over by this leftist clap around,
just being objective since we speak.
It's it,
it's a soft quantify.
When you say like,
you know,
women are x,
you mean most people next is,
it is understood that you speaking in
generalities,
it's annoying to women that aren't like
that telling like shit,
get over it.
It is understood that you're speaking
generalities without general assays.
It's impossible to communicate.
It's a British thing,
British thing.
It's just a not being nit picky.
Dick,
there's a simple addition to that
sentence.
See,
well understood there.
When you say are many men who have gold,
men are leaving
language policing.
You've given it,
you've given it over already.
You have a language policing your
halfway to feminism.
I had a buddy come in for a long time
and he was ugly.
And um,
because he end,
he used to get rejected all the time and
he started getting really fucking angry.
And as he got older we had to stop
hanging out with them because he would,
you know,
he would meet girls who've tried to hit
on them.
They would say no,
and you're like,
fucking lesbians.
He's fucking cunt lessons and just work
out or funny or get money.
I mean,
it's any man can do at least one of
those three.
Anyone can walk out,
anyone can learn to be funny.
During that process,
during that process,
you still have sexual needs.
So he,
he had not accomplished any of those
goals.
So he was not,
would not attractive to these women.
And because he wasn't attracted these
women I witnessed over the course of
knowing him for several years,
I witnessed this massage Negro inside of
him.
And it was based on the interactions
that he had with women that were all
negative,
the interactions he had with women.
He came away feeling bad about himself,
feeling rejected.
And so he started to project that they
were the root cause of this issue.
I had to seek.
You're dealing with a lot of the same
phone as feminists.
Problem is that society has been
architected in such a way that those,
those outcomes,
those rejections are now not just the
norm,
but almost enforced by a woman's need to
reject a man and to see,
you know,
look at this stuff,
unwanted advances,
sexual Harrison,
basically what it means,
it's tough,
but those are the monsters,
the monster women who are trying to push
that they're so small.
It's such a small percentage.
You grossly underestimate the influence
these people have on not just debate in
the media,
but on policy and universities and even
the government.
Look at California.
Yes means yes.
Affirmative consent laws.
This stuff becomes law.
It doesn't California roll and when it,
when it starts in California,
it's spreads elsewhere.
Every unit,
every,
every big American University has a
ridiculous code of conduct that's got
this stuff embedded in it.
And it comes from the,
you know that,
yes,
it comes from the crazies.
I admit,
I willingly admit that most of them were
wonderful and they don't buy into this
shit.
And indeed of course in just what does
it in just two years from 28% of women,
down to 18% of them identify as
feminist.
Fewer than one in five women call
themselves feminists because they see
what we see,
which is that these feminists are all
misaddressed lesbian,
manic,
crazy people,
fine.
But those messengers lesbian at crazy
people are effecting laws in this
country and in my country.
They're effecting conduct codes of
conduct,
the university that dictate a man's
entire future and a woman's entire
future for that matter and their
happiness and good sexual health and,
and the that you know,
at the destination of the species,
the way that men and women interact with
each other's becoming poisoned by these
people.
You grotesquely underestimate their
influence.
If you write,
write them off as a few mad crazies in
student unions,
but they have gigantic purchase on,
on the media and therefore on
politician.
Well,
they certainly do when it comes to
schools in schools to be repeating the
lots of huge issue for,
for
women getting,
getting a sexually assaulted on campus.
Listen though,
your president is parroting these myths
from these pieces.
Yes.
Obama has repeated the,
the sexual harassment myth.
Obama has also repeated the wage gap
myth.
You've dismissing these people are sort
of powerless fringe crazies.
The president of the United States is
repeating their talking points.
Don't tell me these people aren't
influential.
It's nuts.
Well,
that's a different thing,
isn't it?
I mean,
when the president,
the president is really just a guy who
supposed to parrot what everybody else
sort of already believes anyway.
And if that's what the progressive
democratic person,
I don't know if a republican president
would be any different,
they'll be a lot more Jesus talk.
What else would be different?
Would tell the truth.
Trump would tell the truth.
Do you really like Trump or it's a troll
not accusing me of trolling.
What a horrible allegations.
That's,
that's a,
that's a horrible whole remark to make.
Um,
you know,
I really,
I do really like him.
Uh,
do I really want them in the White
House?
You can fill in the gap today,
but,
uh,
but I love him.
I want to in the race for as long as
possible.
Look,
he taps into you and I both,
um,
you know,
obviously I don't have a fraction of
your,
um,
you know,
uh,
reaching an extraordinary audience and
fans.
But we're both in our own ways kind of
counter cultural figures and very
popular counter cultural figures.
And I think that you may not like this,
but I think Trump taps into a similar
vein of frustration and suspicion and
hatred of the establishment of the
political media classes.
I think you and I both benefit from
culture to the tonight,
both benefit from some of the same
instincts that make people quite like
Trump.
They don't like Trump because they
believe what he has to say on about
taxation because they know he's
inconsistent on that.
They might like what he says about
immigration,
but they don't necessarily like the fact
that he,
you know,
was a funder to Hillary and all he got
out of it was her showing up to the
wedding in many cases,
particularly like the way he speaks
about women.
And I think Carly funeral was fearing it
was magnificent in that debate.
But what they do like is the fact that
he,
you know,
doesn't give a shit.
It doesn't apologize and give such a
gigantic,
brilliant bloody nose to the
establishment that has drifted so far
from ordinary people.
You and I both,
uh,
both net beneficiaries of that same
frustration.
And that's why I like Trump because I
think broader look,
he said,
I don't want him in the White House.
I'll be honest.
Okay.
Don't tell anyone this,
but you know,
I don't want them in the White House.
But I do understand why people like him
and the instinct that people have to
like him,
that sort of sense of mischief and a
gadfly Irishness.
The reason people want to vote for him
because it makes the establishment
Republicans so angry and they don't
understand it,
and I totally get that and I have a lot
of sympathy for those people.
I agree with those people on a lot of
points.
I agree with them entirely about the
failings and a corruption of the,
of the media and political establishment
generally.
I totally agree with them on all of that
stuff,
so I wouldn't call myself a Trump fan,
but I am a fellow traveler,
a fellow traveler.
I think that the politicians,
it's the failure,
isn't it?
When it comes
to American politics and American
education,
I think there's some parallels to be
drawn and I think one of the parallels
is that any of these ancient systems
that were established back when the
world was completely different and
didn't have the Internet,
they are no longer valid today.
They're just not.
And you're,
we're clinging to these old ways of
operating that if you try to propose
them today,
no one would buy into it.
No one would buy into American
universities.
If you tried to propose the way you
would,
if you tried to propose the whole
educational system as it is today,
what you put people out of college when
you release them,
they are hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt with no fucking jobs to
be seen.
And the reason it's wrong isn't that
it's anachronistic because there are
things that are not strictly justifiable
with logic,
which nonetheless work best.
Like for example,
the monarchy.
Um,
you know,
there's no,
you can't make a plausible argument as
to why we should have a test.
If you don't,
if you don't,
once you get them out,
somehow or another established a new
empire,
like what happened,
what happened?
And I read anything that's anything
that's a necessary condition.
I just think,
you know,
for example,
the Monica in England,
so you can't make a,
you can't make a plausible,
rational argument to establish a ruling
monarchy in United Kingdom today,
but it works best.
It's the best system,
works the best.
What's best for expressed for you means
we don't get,
you know,
a European style president with his
retinue of,
of Jaguars.
And you know,
and all of the kind of pomp and
circumstance and nonsense that goes with
that.
So that's better.
Well the British people understand,
United Americans understand this too
actually the importance of significance,
the binding power and the value of
tradition in institution and history and
it's something that progressive,
progressive is hate.
All of the assumptions on which these
things are based,
they hate all of the effects of them
too,
which is generally to um,
anyway,
uh,
we,
and I think British people instinctively
understand the value of having a
national icon of figurehead and people
come from all over the world because
they record,
they instinctively understand this too.
Um,
you know,
the monarchy just his works best for us.
They think that should be an earned
position though.
I mean,
isn't that what we're all trying to
accomplish in life is doing this.
This is why I don't believe in grade
internships because I think they
introduced a dangerous element of
egalitarianism into the system.
I think people were,
Terry is there
jumbo shrimp?
They will take bread to rule and they
should be allowed to get on with it.
Born and bred to rule.
You're hilarious.
Now you're fucking trolling now you're
trolling you son of a bitch.
How dare you,
you know why you're trying to introduce
it.
A real of a plausible dangerous level of
egalitarian to colleges and the,
the,
the system that was in place.
And then obviously I do what my point,
my point which,
which is a serious point is that,
um,
just because it's anachronistic doesn't
make it wrong.
There are problems with the,
with the university system in America,
but I don't think just because you
wouldn't construct it like it's
constructed today,
that means you shouldn't do it at all.
No one,
Monica is a good example of that.
No one's saying that.
Well,
I don't know if the Monica is a good
example of that because I think it's
ridiculous.
The same Americans,
Americans have the same [inaudible]
Americans have the same reverence or
adjuster for the office of the United
States.
You know,
the office office of the president,
United States,
reverence for the office.
Not everybody in this country likes any,
you know,
any given president,
but you,
but you will hear Republicans say,
don't say that about Obama.
He's the president.
He's not my president.
I didn't vote for him,
but he is the president.
So show him some respect for American.
No,
come on Americans that Americans do have
an understanding with him than I think
any president because he's just a
fucking terrible obviously,
but we'll do sad is he?
No,
he's reduced your standing in the world.
So badly home.
No idea.
Please tell me.
As a foreigner on my soil,
I will say,
look,
I love America.
I'm one of those,
one of those,
one of those Brits who repeated by
people when I'm not exactly sure if they
have a real stance on it.
Like why is Obama so terrible in
comparison to other presidents
kiss in Europe?
We've seen the future.
Obama wants and we know it doesn't work.
We've seen socialized healthcare.
We've seen,
you know,
in gorgeous of the state.
We've seen these crazy feminist ideas
about the wage gap and,
and um,
and,
and rapes on campus.
We have all this in Europe.
This is why America is great because
it's not Europe.
And everything that I'd seen
here from Obama suggest to me that he
wants to take America,
you know,
it was used to be the case that Europe
follow America's lead in so many
wonderful things,
but it's pop culture and all.
And,
and I personally think we'll lose all
those have been largely positive,
uh,
imports.
But um,
but it now seems like America's
following,
Europe's leading in censorship,
in cracking down on free expression and
creativity and all that kind of stuff
in,
you know,
socialized healthcare.
These things are disasters.
You know,
you will hear from Brits because it's
the correct thing to say.
The NHS is the envy of the world.
I mean,
I would just encourage you where maybe
you don't want to go there,
study.
You don't take any sick relatives but
goes to an NHS hospital.
It is horrific,
horrendous conditions.
Dreadful people die in them all the
time.
There's a scandal a few years ago,
thousands of people dying and you know,
some hospital and the Labor government
just didn't give a shit or didn't do
anything about it.
Even though knew this is not,
you know,
this is not a glittering utopia.
Fine.
There are some problems with American
model and healthcare,
but trust me,
you do not want the NHS.
Um,
you know,
and the way that Obama is pushing
America to be more like Europe I think
is some,
you know,
it's going to hasten its decline as a
world power.
We have seen your future as my colleague
at Breitbart,
James Telling Paul wrote a book,
I think he called it,
I think you called it a bomb Obama mania
and that we've seen your future and it
doesn't work.
And it was a sort of a love letter to
the United States explaining that,
you know,
we've seen where Obama wants to go
because we're living it and it's,
trust me,
it's not what you want.
But if the,
is that really what Obama wants to do
and where he wants to go.
And if that was the case,
like if you compare what Obama stood for
before he got into office and what he's
doing now.
Can anybody work?
What that,
what that,
well,
how about the hope and change website
where they talked about the actions
against whistleblowers.
He is hoping to change website were a
big part of his platform was if the
routine morning whistle blowers actually
made evaporated as soon as he entered
the Oval Office,
Guantanamo whistleblowers,
all the really important style,
the morals,
the moral statements that,
you know,
you know what it was,
is the kind of things that tell you what
sort of man he is.
Um,
the whistle blower stuff,
the Guantanamo,
the things that give you a sense of
where his moral center is.
Those were the things that he jettisoned
the minute he entered the Oval Office.
And that's why I,
why I think,
I mean,
I'm sorry to hear,
but that's,
no,
I think you have a manifesto and you try
and see as much of your manifesto
through as you can and people hold you
to account for any one person really
truly has enough position.
I think it's a bullshit job.
I hope pointed by the United States is
structured is to limit the power of the
president.
Um,
you know,
that you have all of that,
built into the system and it's good.
It's all good.
But he does have a huge influence on
what people talk about,
how they talk about it.
You know,
he makes decisions about foreign foreign
policy and war.
Um,
you know,
I was one of the most important things
that are,
that are a nation can decide about
itself is who it's going to fight.
Um,
you know,
he does make those kinds of decisions
and those kinds of decisions matter.
And he also has the power to move.
Say he does,
but he does based on what,
based on you seeing him talking on
television,
we have no idea what exactly is going on
behind the scene.
It was the president has the executive
authority to,
you know,
to launch whatever.
You know what I'm talking purely in
practical terms,
right?
This guy can send planes to places,
Um,
but everything we've seen from Obama
suggests that,
you know,
he wants,
he wants to take a,
you know,
a sort of a sort of weird progressive
socialized pseudo European approach to
domestic policy,
healthcare taxation.
And this scares us in Europe because we
always,
we looked up to you guys,
you were like,
you know,
the,
you know what it was America for me as a
European and you,
you know,
your viewers are gonna pick holes in
this,
I'm sure.
But for me,
Britain is probably the greatest country
in the world because it didn't invent
democracy or property rights or you
know,
any of those great values that,
that now the world basically revolves
around.
But it was,
it was the best at spreading limit.
Um,
you know,
England in particular spread democracy,
property rights,
freedom around the world and everywhere
that Britain has been is a nice place to
live.
And anywhere that person hasn't been,
you wouldn't want to go to.
Um,
and America is sort of the distillation
of the highest and best values of
Britishness,
you know,
freedom and democracy and free speech
and all this kind of stuff.
America was America.
Like,
you know,
this petri dish of what,
what happened?
If we take the very best of British
values,
the stuff that we've spent centuries,
um,
propagating around the world,
making the world a nice,
prosperous,
you know,
a fair place to live,
what will happen if we take them and we
cut all the crap out and we make a
country like that.
And we did,
it was America,
but that Americans is that you said we
did.
America was established by people
fleeing Britain.
Yes,
of course.
But then they enforce it
because we've been in decline for
centuries,
but,
but importing to America,
the values that Britain spread around
the world have a hundreds of years.
But it wasn't the whole deal that we
wanted to get the fuck away from
everything you guys represented so far.
No,
no.
Not everything is a misnomer.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
America is founded on British values.
America was founded on values that the
British spread throughout the world.
I mean,
these values and those values and these
institutions as well.
I'm talking,
I'm talking about,
uh,
you know,
democracy specifically kind of a
parliamentary version of democracy
rather than a,
the particular model of democracy,
freedom and free.
They were profiting from the TV rights,
um,
you know,
leave their,
that's what they were as these,
these values,
you know,
the Britains spread to Indiana spray to,
um,
you know,
the bits of the Middle East that Britain
went to the nice places to live now
where women,
women can dress,
how they like Kuwait for example,
not terrible place to be where Britain
didn't go.
Saudi not a place you'd want to be,
you know,
any,
any way that Britain has touched has
become better for it.
Look at Japan.
They were all suits.
You know,
they talk our language.
They were our suits,
the influence,
and this is it.
This is Britain,
its influence on the world.
No other country,
nothing else can touch it.
Not Portugal,
not Holland.
Nobody else can touch Britain for just
sheer global influence.
Australia,
Canada,
all places,
Britain's,
that Britain has touched are
dramatically better as a result.
But for me,
the sort of highest distillation of
those,
those values that,
that Britain was spreading around the
world,
it was a America and Obama is tearing
America away from those values.
That's what I don't like.
That's why I said it was a terrible
precedent.
That's why I struggle with,
with him in that office because he seems
to me to be profoundly,
and I know that,
I know this is something that sort of
crazy right wingers on the internet
always say,
but he just seems to me to be profoundly
on American,
on American Pacific respect.
He doesn't value,
he doesn't share the values on which
America was founded.
In what sense though?
And what way doesn't believe in free
speech because they think it's free
speech should be curtailed to save the
feelings of certain,
uh,
intro interest groups and minority
groups who doesn't believe in,
you know,
he doesn't believe in,
why are you saying that?
Where have you heard him say that?
Oh.
Because the,
the effectively the,
the stuff he says about Harrison didn't
have,
you know,
he's,
he's bought into this Harrison nonsense,
this stuff he said about net neutrality,
the stuff he said about the rape campus
stuff,
all of this,
all of these things are satellites of
the free speech argument,
right?
Net neutrality being a satellite of the
free speech or was this all about free
speech?
Net neutrality and what's about
government regulating the internet?
Yes.
It's about regulating.
It's about the gut known.
It's about the government regulating the
internet.
The,
and it needed new channels is about the
government regulating the internet,
having control over what private
companies can do about the relationship
that a private company has with its own
customer.
Right?
You have a service firm,
I don't know what your providers like a
Comcast or whatever.
Um,
you know,
your,
your relationship with Comcast is a
private business arrangement between you
and that company.
Right?
Net neutrality is about the government
trying to intrude on that relationship
and dictating what kind of business
arrangement you can come to with con
Comcast and it's going to say Comcast,
you can not offer this package of
services.
You cannot suggest to the customer that
they might be uh,
a higher tier service for people who pay
more.
Just like,
you know,
you can get a better car if you pay more
or you can get anything else in life.
If you've
got more money,
you get a better version of it.
Right?
You can't do any of that.
We're going to insist because we've got,
we've got this crazy idea of the
internet is some kind of utility,
um,
you know,
like a water or something.
We're going to come in here and we're
going to regulate and control the
relationship that you are a private
company have with you.
A private individual that is,
you know,
that is,
that is at its essence of free speech
argument because of what happens when
you start regulating that traffic.
Now the Internet traffic that is split
down,
you know,
some of it's for Netflix,
some of us for emails,
some it's whatever.
The way in which certain things get,
you know,
what it wants to do is say the all
traffic is neutral.
It is.
That is all equal.
Yeah.
Well do not see the benefit of that.
Do not see that [inaudible] has no basis
in,
do you not see that people would be
concerned with the government being able
to throttle internet away and puts not
what it's about.
Managed operations have them have the
ability to decide how much bandwidth
goes to meringues.
Americans were worrying about the power
of corporations as well.
It's not just worrying about it.
It's knowing the fact that this has been
done illegally already without
regulation.
You think for a second that if the,
if the government has given the power to
regulate how an Internet service
provider delivers it's packets of data
to consumers,
they're not going to then start to
wonder what's in those packets and then
start to say,
well actually,
you know what?
The net neutrality thing was fine.
Like it was a really good idea and we
loved it and we really haven't bring
that to you,
but actually we've decided that this
kind of data is more important.
So we're going to let you do that all
in.
Or indeed we're going to insist that you
prioritize this kind of data and that
has consequences for the free market.
That's conference consequences for
businesses for example.
Um,
you know,
in forcing,
well,
well that's why an open internet where
everyone has access to the same sort of
service is what everybody wants.
No,
uh,
I mean that's what we want.
I mean there is an argument in America,
there's an argument that in insisting
that all packets a day show on the
Internet are treated equally favors new
startups into the market because they
don't have to compete with incumbents
who have privileged access to high speed
an argument.
I'm sure it's not just startups,
it's people like me that are able to
broadcast things.
People that want to set up their own
servers and put together their own
website that does whatever the fuck they
wanted to do.
That.
The idea that that is related in somehow
or another.
It's not about regulation.
It's the absence of I'm fine,
I'm,
I am speaking for the absence of
regulation.
I'm saying we should not regulate that.
We should allow private companies,
private companies to do and have
whatever influence they want.
If you know,
look,
the market works in these,
in these situations,
look what happens when Isp is try to
manipulate Netflix traffic.
Customers complain and they have to stop
and they have to put it back again.
The market works so well for this,
for Internet stuff because everybody
internet so vocal,
they're online already.
They complain about it.
It takes two clicks.
The market works brilliantly for this
stuff.
Why allow the government to come in and
dictate to private individuals and
private corporations what their business
relationship should look like and the
nature of the services that they provide
or money they provide.
One another
that's that's profoundly on American.
Well,
there's a,
a large argument against net neutrality.
There's a large argument online that we
could spend hours going over the pros
and cons of each side of it.
But I think ultimately people have a
distrust in large corporations and a
distrust in the government and either
one of them having control of what has
been like the one thing that's empowered
people in this country is the ability to
put out a message and to get
information.
And the fact that you can do it now just
because,
but it could just be cause throttled.
It could be,
it could be limited.
You could,
it could be blocked.
There's like
seriously theory UN thing.
Have you been paying attention to you as
you went proposal the one who reported
on at first it tell people then.
Okay.
So um,
the UN broadband commission,
which is not one of the upper echelons
of the UN,
um,
he were the one who reported on the
first,
how'd you get the information?
Well,
uh,
so somebody else brought the story,
but I was the one that reports that are
linked.
So my story is the one that went around
the world.
So tweet your story.
Yeah,
I think so.
Powerful,
powerful neuron.
I know,
right?
I'm kind of a big deal.
Um,
that's what I hear.
But
explain the ridiculousness to this idea
that the UN thinks that they're going
to,
but this is,
this is,
this is my argument.
You see this is the government getting
involved
in your say excited and the government
people don't censoring the UN is saying
that and this is wacky crazy stuff,
right?
This report from the UN broadband
commission,
the UN broadband commission,
this is what we have in Europe.
So I don't want you to look from Europe.
Police have become Europe.
We have in in Europe Commission is
specifically set up to find ways it is
paid for by European payers and it's
purpose is to find ways of regulating
the internet.
Right?
That is what it's for.
It is to,
you know,
it has a,
it has a brief to find ways of,
of cutting down on Internet freedoms.
One of the ways it's found to do that is
to get a lot of bat shit crazy feminists
in to say that people who ridicule or
criticize them on the Internet are in
fact guilty of harassment and abuse.
And as a result,
Internet services should be almost
prescreened,
you know,
words should almost be prescreened
before the ever appear on the intentions
is the most crazy bullshit.
You know,
only European come up with this and this
report came out and it was full of holes
and we examined it.
I think I was with the first report when
it's detail about this.
I read about it once or twice and um,
and then I wrote about it a second time
and I think the headline was,
am I the only responsible tech
journalists,
journalists left on the planet,
which is the only perhaps example self
congratulatory of you.
Well,
I'm actually really modest.
I'm actually really humble.
I'm like a very humble person naturally.
But my sub editors just bully me into
this stuff.
You understand how they got to get those
clicks?
I know this is not me at all.
If it were up to me,
I'd just be at home anyway.
So what they want to do is sort of like
pre,
pre brief all of this stuff a pre pre
check it.
And if they don't,
they want to clamp down.
And I ask what you're doing right now is
your saying it's okay for the government
to get involved in this of regulation
of what s of the private relationship
RSPs have with the customers.
But it's not okay for the government get
involved in this kind of regular,
keep the pipes open decks open to all
bullshit they want on the Internet.
No restrictions out of here.
Everybody,
nobody's giving you any different.
They suggesting that that's not going to
be hazy.
You think you're not until it's already
in place.
I mean the,
the UN thing is essentially a Trojan
horse,
right?
I mean that's really what it is.
That's what was so disturbing about it
is the idea that the UN could get in and
get involved and somehow or another
punish a social media websites that uh,
and,
and make them responsible for what the
users' posts.
You post some inflammatory,
ridiculous shit and they let him see
that their name never.
But if you did,
if you went on a fucking late night,
cocaine fueled Twitter rampage and you
typed a bunch of ridiculous shit about
women with no with no like some women
are there.
Ours who had all just women.
If you do blah,
blah,
some dreary nit picker like,
yeah,
I guess I could me,
dude,
that's my
fellow.
Here comes another true thing.
Everybody's got their thing.
I like to leave a mark.
You're a Drury.
Nitpicking like to leave a mark on
people.
I have my hair,
you'll go nitpicking.
You know,
I mean,
look this,
there's actually an interesting
discussion around around this and it's
that,
um,
it's about comment sections and
commenting what people are allowed to
say on the Internet,
right?
There's this huge trend at the moment
and almost every progressive publication
as either closed their comments section,
we'll indicated that they might,
in the early days of the Internet,
you had these tech savvy progressive's
disproportionately based on coastal
cities,
coastal cities who said,
because the only people they knew who
used the internet,
we're like of them were hipsters and
coastal types.
Who said that the Internet was going to
create this extraordinary,
an amazing new world where everyone
could express their opinions.
It was going to democratize knowledge
and democratize power.
Um,
and the presumption they made was that
everyone,
the Internet was going to be nice.
Well,
most people aren't very nice and most
people are particularly aren't nice when
I'm in that as a compliment by the way,
cause I hate most people.
Most people hate nice people.
It's boring.
I let people who have vicious and bitchy
and mischievous,
you know?
No,
I just,
every time I do a show this,
it just comes back it Gavin McInnes did
not even wait.
Gavin McInnes did not even wait.
I was on his show for three minutes and
he's like,
you have any idea how gay you are?
Well that's Gavin style.
I'm a kinder,
gentler.
You waited an hour,
hour and five minutes.
Fine.
I'll skip.
Guess what you just said was so good.
I like people that are fishes and bitchy
and
interesting.
Well there's plenty of assholes out
there.
You're going to have them sent to be
nice.
So I'm sure you get on tougher.
They tend to be very tentatively,
pathologically.
And Helen Dario,
I like.
People are a bit more dangerous.
I'm always attracted to it.
So you like shitty people online.
See people,
I like people who are more interested.
I like people to step outside the
Overton window.
I like people who pushed the boundaries.
I like people who are dissidents.
I like people who are disreputable and
mischievous and interesting.
I'm attracted to interest in people as I
am.
Right.
Not all during it because,
but uh,
you know,
I love people like that fascinated me.
I think they're the people who pushed
society for the people who come up with
a great,
interesting theories.
Just can't,
sometimes they're just cans.
But that can be funny too,
that,
you know,
that's the entertainment.
I mean,
I,
for example,
I'm not going to add to the sum total of
human knowledge.
I'm just going to wind a lot of people
up for 30 years and hopefully something
good about yourself short.
You're,
and you're making some very interesting,
do you know,
you are humble.
You make interesting points.
Let's go back to the point please.
The um,
the,
uh,
the comment section stuff right there.
This was based on a presumption that
everybody on the Internet was going to
be,
you know,
like a Twitter employee,
Coco blogger.
Yeah.
So they come out of this idea,
you know,
as great Internet,
social media,
social is gonna be the new thing.
We are the guardians going to throw it
to newsrooms,
open to the public and the assumption
that,
you know,
the Guardian readers and people who live
in north London,
which is something like Portland or
Brooklyn,
Brooklyn or whatever sort of,
um,
sort of north of London and it's like
the hipster enclave.
No,
it's more actually sort of like posh,
rich liberals.
Um,
but it's not quite,
it's not directly comparable,
but it,
you know,
instead of like,
roughly like that,
you know,
they were going to be homogenous,
nice,
polite lefties with the correct opinions
about things.
Actually what's happened is it took
longer.
It took longer than I anticipated.
But what's happened is that ordinary
people now can open Twitter accounts too
and not sufficiently technologically
educated to do so.
And what all of these progressive media,
um,
uh,
companies are discovering the Mike's the
boxes,
the buzz feeds,
the caucus of this world are discovering
that most people don't agree with them.
They are just,
they've never,
I know it's shocking,
but most people don't believe you should
kill all men.
Most people don't believe that white
people that,
you know,
black people can't be racist.
I,
most people don't believe in this extra
everything on salon.com nobody believes
everything else down.
Doesn't believe what's on salon.com.
Look,
it's impossible to believe those things
in good faith because you have to lie to
make that you have to lie so much to
yourself and to others in order to make
those arguments that I don't,
I just,
it is one long practical joke.
That site,
it is just a gigantic,
it's the Santa,
I'm convinced it's funded by the Koch
brothers to discredit a liberalism.
I'm convinced,
absolutely convinced.
If you trace,
if you trace the sell on money back far
enough,
you will discover,
you will discover the surname coke
because it is the only explanation for
how badly sal on discredits
progressivism is the only exposure.
Just today they published another
editorial from this fucking pedophile.
Um,
you know who I wrote about and he
wouldn't even dare bring my name up
because he's too scared to get into it
with me cause he knows he will lose.
I probably,
you know,
he published this thing about how,
I'm a pdf farb I don't act on it.
Um,
right after I had exposed a pedophile,
Sarah Nyberg in Gamer Gate,
right.
And it went all over the world.
And it was this huge story that I
brought the,
hold on,
I'm going to stop [inaudible].
I exposed this,
I have a brand on file.
I exposed this pedophile,
you know,
she was backed up and they doubled all
the social justice warriors.
Doubledown protected her because she
was,
you know,
on message.
Basically,
she had the right politics.
So they stuck around a kiddy fiddler.
This is the state of the modern left,
um,
directly after that with a coincidental
timing.
Sal on publishes this thing by a
pedophile saying,
oh,
I'm a bit of hope,
I don't act on it.
Which is precisely the defense that
there's this person who used.
Um,
so I respond and I,
you know,
and I,
I did a,
I did a very good piece of knowing,
I urge all of your listeners to seek it
out because it really is excellent
journalism.
Yeah.
It was called something like,
this is why the left.
So this is why liberals,
this is why progressive's stick up for
pdf files explains why,
um,
pdf files can get away with this stuff.
And why white progressives and liberals
back then,
um,
you think people back pedophiles or they
make excuses for them.
They make excuses for them as just
today.
Today they gave us space to this guy who
was a pedophile about whom there is
horrific stuff online which hasn't come
out yet,
which you know,
you should watch this space for that.
Cause I know Steven Crowder knows about
some of it and sort of why,
um,
excuse me.
Uh,
you should,
you should just go,
who wrote this?
Oscar?
Did he give me a second?
Yeah,
under his own name.
This is how brazen they'll row a second
piece for salon today playing the victim
saying that he came out as a pdf file
and he's been subjected to right wing
hate so that he says this is the right
action.
On one hand I'm the creative file and I
think so I'm a pedophile and I don't act
on it.
And I did this like peace and everyone
like came out and said that it was
really supportive and it was really
great and that they help people to get
through their own experiences and
everyone's really sympathetic except the
right wing hate machine meaning me.
Well they didn't dare mention me by
name.
Um,
who are the right wing hate machine?
Well apparent according to him.
Um,
you know,
uh,
exit the right wing hate machine had the
temerity to say we think pedophilia is
role and why is that on giving a
platform for it to this guy when there's
so much dirt on the Internet suggesting
that he is physically touched young
girls for example.
Um,
you know,
and I'm going to,
yeah,
there is a completely different arguing.
Well this is the thing that you sell on.
Gave a platform to this guy in San Juan
ought to have known about this
allegation.
If you're going to,
if you're going to make space on your
platform for a self confessed pedophile
and you will,
you will only find this on the left is
what I mean by the left.
Sticking a couple of hours.
They make excuses when they try to
legitimize them.
They tried to give it,
they tried to habilitate this as,
as an unfortunate sexual orientation
rather than,
you know,
these people being dangerous predators
that we need to be protected from
sitting there.
But you're saying all I've seen is
discussing this,
but no,
honestly all bullshit aside like
psychologists and sociologists and
neuroscientists or tried to figure out
what it is that causes someone to have
these desires.
But we know from the transgender debate,
the left doesn't care about that.
When it cares about is who it can,
uh,
you know,
where it can place people in the
oppression Olympics and the victim
hierarchy and pet.
If I'm telling you I'm warning you now
is the worry,
I'm warning you now is that as the
native files,
pedophiles are going to be the next,
transgender has been one.
Now they've won,
they've won.
That battle is over.
Um,
do you think so?
Yes.
Honestly,
absolutely stay.
It's done and dusted
by we,
I mean people who actually wanted to
find out what the science said to
continue to invest in things that are
now unfundable um,
you know,
certain bits of research that don't
agree with a progressive consensus,
which now can't get funding for that
consensus is what kind of research?
Well,
um,
so transgender,
the transgender question is complex and
difficult and for example,
Johns Hopkins doesn't do the surgeries
anymore.
The guy who used to run it there is a
very outspoken critic of transition
surgeries is not the best treatment
pathway.
Um,
they all end up killing themselves
anyway by most most metrics,
no improvement in suicide rates.
Um,
my view on this is,
you know,
we're probably going to look back in 30
years and wonder how we could ever have
been so cruel as to allow somebody with
a psychiatric delusion to start hacking
at themselves to make reality conform to
their own delusions.
But I'm not but by,
but by we earlier,
what I meant was people who want to be
science lead on this and instead what
the left very,
it was very,
it was,
there were on the cover of Time magazine
Trans,
you know the,
the Trans thing is the next civil rights
frontier.
They very clearly articulated,
they gave us all the clues we needed to
work out how they were going to fight
this one.
Right?
And we just didn't pay any attention at
the time or some,
some people didn't.
Um,
they set it up as the next gay or the
next bisexual or the next lesbian.
It's just the next frontier in the civil
rights struggle.
I'm telling you,
pedophilia is the,
is the one after that.
But don't you think that if you are a
person and you are of sound mind and
body and you have a desire to be a woman
and you've had this desire your whole
life,
but you were born a man,
shouldn't you be able to do whatever the
fuck do you want to do other people?
Isn't that really what it is?
There are people who wake up one day and
think their arm doesn't belong to them.
We don't cut their arm off because they
think it doesn't belong to them.
There are people who believe that they
have someone draw on you permanently.
I think it looks hot.
Thank you very much.
I like it too.
How far?
The sleeves?
Just sleeves.
But you see my point like,
no.
Why?
Why brain tattoo tattoos with being born
as long gender choice.
First of personal permanent.
There is a view that you should be able
to do whatever you want to your body.
My argument,
we,
yeah,
fine,
but don't make the state pay for it.
I don't want to pay for your cock off
because you're mentally ill.
Um,
I will try to dissuade you from doing it
and I,
I should have a right to say in a
national newspaper,
which now you don't,
please don't do this.
Well,
I think the argument,
you can't get published in national
newspaper,
this argument,
you cannot get published by saying,
please don't do pizza.
Have transitioned surgery.
It's the wrong treatment pathway.
You cannot get published because of
public opinion,
because people were worried about the
blow back from the left.
Right.
And these things,
they just dream left.
I mean,
if I see,
if ever you needed evidence that the
trainees are mentally ill,
it's tranny campaigners.
I mean,
the transgender lobby are nuts.
The reason journalists don't want to
write about this stuff or don't want to
enter the dangerous territory,
is that what they are?
And the receiving end of afterwards is
just,
I mean,
I've,
I've had it,
well,
I've had it to my,
my confrontation,
the,
yeah,
of course.
And you know,
you're right about that.
It's so unfair.
You know,
these women who are getting the crappy
now of them by somebody who's not only
unfair if you don't say that you used to
be a man,
but you should have the ability to say
yes for new option to opt out and they
shouldn't.
I mean,
what are we going to do?
So any man who wants to,
any man who wants to be a women's MMA
fighter,
we're just going to basically give him a
gold line pathway to the championship
because nobody's going to a woman's
gonna wanna get in a ring with him and
have her jaw broken.
That's not okay.
I think,
you know,
it's perfectly reasonable to say if you
weren't born a woman,
you don't get to fight in a women's
competition.
I think that's perfectly reasonable,
perfectly reasonable.
And uh,
objective.
There's the in scientifically valid too,
but there's a science behind you and I
both on the wrong side of,
of popular opinion on this one.
We're not,
well,
I know we often,
no,
not what ordinary people think,
but the media,
the media and political establishment of
made up their minds on this and it's,
it's gone.
It's gone.
How did the writing this real
interesting that right gets this wrong
so it gets this wrong everyday.
The reason I win,
I think there's no repercussions in
supporting it.
That's why there's no repercussions in
supporting,
well,
they're all trans gender to be,
we ought to,
I mean,
look,
you know what?
I'm saying to me,
[inaudible],
it's a woman.
Get over it.
She should be able to fight men.
There's no repercussions.
But if you say you're out of your
fucking mind and because you're always
going to self determination and all the
rest of it.
Yes,
no that's true.
But that is entirely a construction of
the left,
entirely construction to the left,
the aggressive,
progressive,
aggressive,
progressive and you know,
and these people who you just missed
earlier is fringe nutcases.
They have entirely dictated what you
were allowed to say on that subject.
And if you don't say the right thing for
now,
what I think,
I think it goes like this and then it
comes back.
No,
right now it's come and give me an
example of us.
Give an example of what's come back back
right now to progressive fuel.
Progressive's have one,
a um,
a society aren't women shit often
listen,
does progressives,
they won gay marriage.
They will.
They will,
absolutely do you don't,
you don't think,
you don't think gay marriage is good
cause you don't want to get married.
Do you want to have an excuse?
Well just around town.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's what it is.
I don't want engaged.
I don't want gays to become,
so Bosch,
we sell to be judging judged by other
people's standards,
but being born gay's not fun.
And if you have to be gay,
if you have to,
you know,
Jesse Anal sitting there,
we'll look.
I'm having a wonderful time.
You know I love me.
I am a note stretch of the imagination,
self loathing.
I'm very happy with who I am.
So how very English my sex life.
Well,
because it hasn't been an easy road.
This now rather be gay or be that Fat
lady from Kentucky that won't marry gay
people.
Kim Davis.
Yes.
Who would you rather they be?
Okay.
Just got fucked over.
Way Worse than you'll Kim Davis.
The Shit is God damn genetic.
Roll the dice possible.
Not a difficult,
difficult thing to southern fucking
blotchy skin.
If I were heterosexually wouldn't be Kim
Davis,
so be Kim Kardashian.
I doubt it.
Not if you were born in her life and
lived her life fucking body
and that I have the actionetics fucking
snake.
I've probably had sex with more black
men.
This their entire family.
Nay guys,
I don't know.
I don't think she's hot.
Listen,
I'm going to call Dash Dashlane.
I wish I was stupid.
I could have been such a great like
Bimbo.
I would've,
I would've been so good.
You think so?
I would have been so good at it.
I don't think so.
Intelligence has been coast.
I don't think you're ruthless enough.
Maybe kind have a nice guy.
He's a secret thing.
I didn't like you think too much.
And it's also,
you're like contemplating things and
even though you make rash
generalizations,
obviously well studied each individual
issue in general.
Attorney get picker,
Riri nitpicking.
This is it.
Now I'm changing it on my phone.
Thank you.
I like,
you know,
I think we see a lot of these things.
I think we have a lot of ideas in common
a lot.
Um,
I think that I'm trying to stick up for
men even though you agree with me,
just to go from that
stopping pussies,
that stuff.
The reality is it's not that easy.
Exactly.
That's why some people rise to the top
and most don't because it's not easy.
Cool.
Get out of the bed and get your fucking
shit.
I am the biggest meritocratic you will
ever meet.
You can keep just holding on and let
anybody tell you you can't.
God dammit.
That's what we don't.
You don't need to have your handheld and
laws changed and we need to make it safe
for,
for men,
for men space.
We met in this country being ignored by
women and we have to put a stop to that.
We not gonna.
They're not attractive.
Why are they not attractive?
Because women are smart.
They know these guys are pussies.
They don't want this pussy shooting up
fucking disease load inside of them and
making some dump fucking kid that they
have to raise.
They don't want it so they reject these
fools.
These fools are there because you can
get me on a little styrofoam plate and a
fucking supermarket.
It's too easy to buy milk.
It's too easy to get your vegetables.
You don't have to do a goddamn thing.
It's easy.
That's why.
That's why these guys are pussies
because the world is soft.
They're like lottery winners.
You ever met a lottery winner?
They never keep their money because it's
too fucking easy.
They don't appreciate it.
And these guys that have gotten through
this shitty,
dull gray life
cause they don't like you.
You don't even like you become someone,
somebody with like you.
Fuck.
That's the solution.
It's not changed the laws or get on the
top of a mountain with a torch.
We have to stop these women from ruining
these men look at them and they're
running away.
They're running away to be by themselves
because the women won't have them
anymore.
Cool.
Well they don't even like themselves.
You gotta understand dude,
I'm with you on a lot of this.
Okay?
Don't stick up for pussies.
It's not good for them.
It's not good for anybody.
I want them to have self confidence.
I want to work out the way we do it.
Hold their hand.
Fucking let them cry and your sh you're
expensive suit.
I think
I wouldn't let them near it
is that great line in the lost world.
A second Jurassic Park movie.
It's like careful the suit cost more
than your education.
I'm not a big fan of the military.
I'm not a big fan of like people I care
about love joining the army,
going over and killing people overseas
unless it's absolutely necessary of
course.
But uh,
I'm a big fan of,
I think a lot of people would benefit
from fucking boot camp.
I think I agree with you and I might not
be such a fucking pansy if we'd had it
comfortable,
goddammit.
No,
I mean like,
you know,
if if I'd been through bootcamp,
I might not chosen to be gay.
Um,
watts,
that's probably been the number one
spot.
I think more people are and bootcamp
than anywhere you go.
Now he gets to roll.
My whole fucking 30 guys are all
together.
You don't think a few months off and I
let at school.
So that's what I'm saying.
I was working my way through the cricket
team,
especially when they're on a boat.
We didn't have a lot of navy,
almost would have been there.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
The navy week isn't it?
Was it like black guys?
That was the joke was the cricket.
You get some Indian dudes,
right?
They're pretty good at cricket.
Indian dude's sorry.
Huh?
Too much curry.
No,
smells the look,
you're not allowed to say that.
He knows all that to say that,
but that,
you know,
it's not,
it's not a race thing.
It's not a race thing,
but there's a certain diet like in a Oh
duck goalie,
Bangladeshis ever certain Diane it gives
us,
it's a very older three particular,
um,
and I can say this is somebody who's
banged a lot of Asian guys.
Um,
you know,
there's a very particular odor to like
Bengalis Topanga,
Deschutes,
the kind of food data's pretty heavily
spiced fish that can stuff that's
actually those people as Asia.
That's interesting because yeah,
we call the major weak automations and
stuff.
But you know,
it's the same with,
I don't know whether it's a race there.
Mike Cleaner is a Ghanian Mike made is
like a Ghanaian.
I'm Muslim and I'm such a good person.
Ghanaian Ghanian from gone.
Gone it.
Yeah.
I'm really good person,
so I let her keep her on in my house and
stuff,
even though it's a bit like kind of just
a bit terrifying just so she reads a
crime and you're your man and she's
praying and I'm like,
I hope I'm not telling him making bacon.
You're paying for this.
Um,
no,
but why quite often do during Ramadan is
like is I reheat last night's KFC,
um,
just to talk to her.
Um,
but no,
I,
you know,
Shit.
But she,
you know,
she has a very pungent aroma and I'm
sure it's,
I don't,
I don't know.
Is that a race thing or you were even
allowed to say that he liked,
well,
you're not supposed to be really on you.
It's like saying men are different from
women.
You're not really supposed to say any
more.
But no,
there is,
there is a certain,
I mean I quite like it and I like those
guys.
I'm always asking if she's got hot suns
and she would never tell me.
I'm wondering why I quite like it,
but the area.
But there is definitely that.
I mean like if she's,
if she's been in and she's been mopping
and whatever,
you can smile and like two hours later
and I come home,
I know she's been there.
Wow.
That's bizarre.
You're like a wolf.
Did you have really good,
I do have a really good sense of smell
actually.
That's weird for a gay guy.
Why?
Because I would think dude smell like
shit.
No like stinky.
I would think that would be like,
like they put flowers,
hours,
perfume and women quite like how men
smells.
He imagined men into men.
They quite like it.
Oh okay.
That does.
Yeah.
So some guys like be,
oh yeah,
some guys smell bad.
I perspire quite a lot,
but I don't smell like I,
I if,
if I get,
I get sort of grotesque,
but let's change the subject.
There's,
I know women that like the way dude
stink when they get back from the gym.
No,
I quite like fucking stay quite like
they like it dirty bitches dirty.
I would be such a such a whore.
Right?
Well,
you know,
there was a bus,
there was a study such a slot.
I'd be pregnant at 12 I would have had
so many abortions by now.
Wow.
There was a university of Rome,
I believe,
did a study on homosexuality and they
had a theory that the reason why,
um,
people became gay was a variation on the
x chromosome.
And so because there was a
disproportionate amount of homosexual
men that were birthed from women that
were promiscuous,
so just exceeding how terrible women
are.
I think some men just see it,
see it really early and think that is so
much crazy just to like,
just to come in something.
I have to deal with that.
No,
thank you.
I'm gonna go with boys.
That's so ridiculous.
I'm coming to you as a straight man and
you're talking nonsense for the most
part.
Great.
I went gay to get it.
My mother.
That's how it's revenge.
I'm kind of a revenge homosexual.
Like a wall.
Like a werewolf.
Is that a convertible?
Yeah.
Well,
you'd be like the full moon.
Your mother turned you right?
Yeah.
It's tired.
No.
So I went and because it wasn't
sufficiently scandalous that I lost my
virginity in a interracial five,
some of the drag Queen,
um,
that's not enough.
I know.
So I started probably,
I started bringing him,
they're like 13,
maybe 13,
drag queens,
interracial drive,
some five.
So yeah,
it was grass.
The first one.
Yeah.
Well I was just fucked for life until
you get gone.
Uh,
no.
So I switched my home black boys
instead.
And that she was upset about,
um,
she just,
was it a racial thing that she was just
coming down and they was just these
black guys with like,
you know,
with like cocaine and pills out on the
breakfast table at 7:00 AM 14.
Yeah.
I think people would have a problem with
that whole,
the black guys a couple of years older,
not a hugely alto.
And they went to,
they went to the bad schools.
I mean,
what's the go down cool.
Baddies can,
we didn't have black people in my school
blow and fucking their son.
Um,
so yeah,
no,
and then,
and then it just,
and then it just sort of,
I just got stuck in a row and now it's
kind of a bad habit.
But you know,
I wrote a column about this like I'm so
bored of being gay and everybody took it
as a joke.
It's actually one of my serious things
will ever,
ever written.
Um,
I'm only really attracted to things that
are transgressive that are naughty.
And I talked,
you spoke about this earlier,
like I like dangerous,
difficult people.
I only really sexually excited by things
that are forbidden and now gay people
are endlessly Molly cuddles and
flattered and sucked up to in society is
kind of the sexist lost its luster for
me.
I'm thinking,
I think I thinking that I might go
heterosexual,
I might,
I might do something that's going to
take you think I might do some things.
I might do something that you know is
going to invite ridicule and criticism
and he's going to make given me a more
difficult life.
I might become a straight white male
with all due respect.
I think you'll find it very difficult to
find suitors that are worthy of your
appearance with us.
If you're a woman,
you can dance back and forth through
those worlds with little to no worries.
Women who's in full words all the time,
suck a few Cox,
take some deck and get fucked by five
guys.
One of them's a drag queen.
He tells stories,
code black guys,
fuck you Nigga.
Fuck fuck.
They're going to think about that.
Worry them.
Yeah,
they're just going to go.
This guy is just to guy.
I just can't just,
you can't trust him.
He love me.
Like I'm surrounded by women all the
time in a friendly way.
They were a friend,
but because that's what you are,
but they'd let me do you understand the
difference?
Let me fuck some of them.
But which those are the ones that would
let you fuck them.
No,
you know what I'm saying?
I ain't trying to be nice to your
friends.
Wait ones.
It'll let you fuck him.
You don't want to fuck.
No,
you're probably right.
Trust.
Make sure the hot ones being that
friend,
they're going to fuck a guy who,
uh,
never,
never had a doubt.
So it's true.
So I'm going to get really bad,
a bad quality of woman.
If I go straight,
stick with the black dudes.
When we got,
she got an animals or something,
become a nicker file.
Now I transgender really flipped a
switch.
It could be a trainee,
I think such a pretty girl.
Yeah,
but you got to keep it just in case,
you know,
she and I would throw my toys out,
the prop Z or z or my pronouns are like,
here,
here.
My pronouns are.
Fuck you motherfucker.
It's amazing.
The new pronouns,
Harvard University is trying to get
people to use these new pronouns.
I mean,
you're winning on this so sided.
Never transition just to antagonize
people because they'd be like,
yeah,
I still got to take,
we still gotta call me.
She,
um,
that's the move,
right?
Say I'm a woman or wait until I'm in
trouble.
I'm gonna pull,
I'm gonna pull a Bradley Manning.
I'm going to wait until I get in
trouble.
And then to elicit sympathy from idiots.
I'm going to go trends.
Are you trying to say that that's a
Bradley Manny did.
How dare you,
you would never make that application.
Chelsea Manning,
by the way,
gender week.
I missed [inaudible].
I still called Bruce Bruce.
What?
Of course you do.
60 years as he had it.
I Dunno.
I'm not even going to be nicer.
You fuck to dude.
Well,
yeah,
you're right.
It should.
It shouldn't be a women's company.
Doosan,
it's amazing stuff.
Amazing media.
Now Caitlyn Jenner won the men's hundred
repeaters like stuff.
Now this,
is that what they're saying now when she
wanted the correct way to describe,
uh,
his,
his or her accomplishments as an
athlete,
the technically correct way to do it is
to use the new name and the past
accomplishments.
She won the men's whatever.
I don't even know what's kind of
supposed to be one of the guys he
competed in the Olympics with believes
that this whole transition to him
becoming a woman had to do with taking
steroids for the Olympics after he got
off the steroids.
Oh,
for sure.
That's a big mean.
If you live in that family,
if you live in the Kardashian family,
you know,
it is a war of attention seeking.
And this is attention seeking something.
I understand,
you know,
and they're constantly trying to one up
one up each other and everyone thinks
Kim's got the lead and everyone,
you know,
and everyone thinks,
I'll go Kim.
And then Bruce comes out and says,
well,
the nuclear bomb,
I got one for you,
drops the fucking atomic,
but the neutron bomb,
whatever,
you're a weapon of mass destruction,
analogy of choices,
uh,
drops this bomb.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I can,
I want to get vanity fair.
Yeah,
watch this shit.
I shit.
Nobody cared about him at all for the
decade.
It was on the show.
Who was the whipping boy show?
And he got so sick of it.
It was like,
I really,
really need some tension.
I live in the cabinets,
is a Kardashian family.
I've got to do something.
But I also think that he probably came
as a slot.
Chloe's fat.
Kim's a slut.
She's married with children.
Sir.
I wasn't a judgment.
Trust me.
I mean,
I identified with her,
I told you about,
you know,
Kim's a slot,
Chloe's flat.
Okay.
Calories,
fat.
And Bruce is a woman,
you know,
it's like they all have something,
right?
Well,
he certainly does now.
I mean,
he may not have it anymore when with his
face at the very least,
he turns his face into a woman's face.
And you know,
I love it.
I was trying to send it to me.
I want to make a serious point about
this section.
What I love about the transgender debate
is how damaging it is to feminism.
Um,
trying to,
hold on.
It's about,
actually,
it was my original point,
right?
This is where you were going to go,
isn't it?
There's something that feminine,
we say about transgender,
particularly the male to female
transgender is why do they always choose
such classically feminine
looks?
Why don't they become what we want,
which is a sort of genderless fat blue
head on pip hell brigade.
Like if you're going to go trends,
what they want is for you to cut,
become kinda queer.
They want you to become,
you know,
blue allergic,
Chris asexual disaster of a human being
rather toenail high heels,
people who've,
men who become women become women like
very stereotypically women.
And this is interesting because this is
um,
this is a sort of physical manifestation
of a psychological
cool problem for feminism.
And it is this,
if you accept that people can be born
with the wrong brain,
that a man can be born with a woman's
brain or a woman can be worn with a
man's brain.
That goes a long way to destroying 40
years of gender politics and gender
theory,
which says that all sexuality and all
gender is socially constructed.
Then that's why men behave like men do.
And women behave like women do.
If you accept and you put on the cover
of Time magazine in or Vanity Fair,
a person who has had the wrong brain in
the wrong body and when they transition
they take on new characteristics,
new forms of behavior on all the rest of
it.
You are admitting that some of these
qualities are innate or biological,
that there is such a thing as a male
brain.
And a female brain.
This is something that feminists have
been denying for decades,
and it is incredibly damaging to the,
to the feminist project,
to the idea that everything is cool
because when I want to break down the
gaps between men and women,
they want to make girls play with
action,
man and boys or just boys up as
princesses.
What they're suggesting is the all
gender is taught that it's a social
construct that we teach boys how to be
boys.
So we should teach boys to,
you know,
be nice instead of violent.
You know,
and this is toxic masculinity thing.
Well,
what transgenderism demonstrates quite
clearly if we accept it as face value as
progressive's us too,
is that there is indeed such a thing as
a male brain.
And there is indeed such a thing as a
female brain,
um,
that being the case,
ordinary people have them too.
Uh,
and that explains why,
for example,
there aren't as many women in stem
subjects.
It explains why men have certain
behavioral characteristics,
you know,
and all of this stuff that feminists
have been telling us is just society and
Patriarchy and conditioning.
Hmm.
Hang on a minute.
You can't hold these two beliefs
simultaneously.
You cannot believe both of these things
in tandem.
You have to pick one.
And this is,
you know,
the reason that some people on the quiet
acquaintances Yaz to get a on the
political right and quite enthusiastic
about the transgender thing is they know
it unravels the feminist project and it
unravels two generations of crazy
progressive feminism in one fell swoop
because it demonstrates,
um,
by their own admission what total
bollocks.
The idea of constructed gender as well.
It certainly is fascinating when you
watch people being celebrated for
traditional feminine appearances.
Absolutely traditional accepted feminine
appearances dresses,
but they would kill to be fat blue.
How,
you know,
that's what they're showing me.
That's the most durable.
They won't have to be ugly like they are
Trans America.
The cover,
the vanity fair,
was it Vanity Fair or New Yorker?
Whichever one they want her to be ugly.
Like they are ugly and they are ugly,
which is why they became feminist in the
first place.
There are gauges why they're left wing
it.
My favorite feminist are the ones that
will never accept transcend
transgenders.
Oh,
the tests.
Yes.
I love them too.
It's a tough,
this,
this woman I told you about,
the concentration camp woman,
she's a tough,
I think all she,
she's accused of being a tough,
these people who say that I'm
transgender women or not women,
uh,
because they haven't had a woman's lived
experience.
In fact,
all they're doing is acquiring the
victim hood mantle by which they sort of
admit the whole Jake,
you know,
in the courts of this,
in order to be a turf,
you have to sort of admit that there's
such thing as a female privilege and
what they're basically saying it as a
transgender person,
you can never acquire the full degree of
female privilege.
Yeah.
Because you can't claim your oppressed
victimhood status and get special
dispensation or you can't do any of
those things because you're not a real
woman.
You never had a woman's experience.
We don't want you,
I love them.
I love them because they're just the
most brilliant example of let's just
dysfunctional,
fucked up,
left on left violence.
It's wonderful.
Or this sort of house of cards of
ludicrous theory that's totally
internally inconsistent.
This is one of these,
the one of those times in which it just
implodes,
that stuff's accelerated and they're
eating themselves at a staggering rate.
When I wrote about this,
I wrote about this in a,
in another great piece that you're,
oh,
what's it called?
It's called minority wars.
And my point in this was that,
um,
in the last,
if the last 10 years have been bit about
setting men against women and find,
you think men are just man the fuck up
and I know you're entitled to that view.
Um,
I have,
I taken a slightly more compassionate
view of this stuff.
Um,
if you,
if you believe that the last 10 years,
I think most people do the progressive
project has been sister set women
against men.
The next 10 years is going to be even
worse.
The next 10 years is going to set
sexuality against sexuality,
race against race,
gender against gender.
Um,
so you're gonna get Hispanics versus
blacks in America is Hispanic.
Hispanics for example.
Um,
uh,
that's interesting because Hispanics
don't have the guilt about slavery that
white people do.
So when Hispanics or running cities like
Baltimore,
the policing is going to be brutal.
It is getting,
you're never going to,
you will never see.
You will never have seen anything like
it.
Um,
what,
what Hispanics,
Hispanics are going to be the going to
be the demographic majority in this
country.
They,
well,
they don't have the same guilt.
They don't have the white guilt that
allows black lives matter to flourish.
Right?
They only reason black lives matter is a
thing is because of white guilt.
You really think that you don't think
it's because of black people are getting
fed up,
that they see people getting shot for no
reason.
They see.
It's definitely a pleasing,
definitely placing form.
But you can swap being teasers on their
body.
You can in the black people as indeed I
do with my body and in many cases,
uh,
and nonetheless not think the black
lives matter is the best thing for black
people with black lives matter.
Perpetuates a culture of victim hood,
which is,
I want to do this.
Not really black.
What's his name is Shaun King.
Yeah,
he's still,
you know,
Shaun King story is amazing.
It's amazing.
This guy,
and you know what,
he came back with this male Rachel came
back with this blog posts.
You know,
it's another wonderful story of Brooke.
Um,
he came out with this because you break
that story too.
Of course I brought that story.
How dare you.
Um,
I know I put that,
um,
well actually you told me about that on
Twitter.
That's how I found out.
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
he,
he comes back after all this reporting
and says,
oh,
well the man,
they're,
they're right about everything except
the amount on my birth certificate is
not my real dad.
My mum had an f like throws his mom
under the bus because my mom was a slot
30 years ago.
Effectively.
Um,
and I'm not getting any more
interaction.
Never asked about who my dad is.
I don't know anything about him.
I've never lost in 30 years who my dad
is.
Okay.
All right,
fine.
Carry on.
The only thing I know about him for
absolute short,
I didn't know his name.
I don't know who he is.
I don't know where he is.
The only thing I definitely know about
him as if he was black,
isn't it possible DNA.
Social.
Well,
he really,
he didn't like,
didn't acknowledge it was a black,
a black political,
well this is what I was thinking.
I was like kissing someone and get a
cup.
You know,
like they do in the movies where you
should put him on 23 and me.
But there was a black political action
committee.
They said they'd give $25,000 a black
lives matter.
If he submits to do a DNA test,
did he wouldn't do it at black political
action committee said put this to rest.
We'll give $25,000 a black lives matter
and he wouldn't do it.
So we're in the situation now.
I know these things.
Tell me all I need to know now we're in
a situation with Shaun King has
pronounced Shaun King innocent,
but you don't have to ask any more
questions and you just got to take his
word for it.
Well,
sorry,
I don't,
there's still going.
The guy's white is still a big part of
black lives matter.
Well,
he's one of the figureheads.
I mean I think he's a thing like
couldn't you be white?
And also think that black lives matter,
like the end
piece is identity politics.
They didn't want you,
they don't want you,
you,
you have no village to speak on those
issues.
It's like,
and I was just no,
right.
Speak about feminism.
Um,
you know,
this is,
this is why it's so damaging to black
lives matter.
The fact that,
you know,
all of their figurehead seemed to end up
either being lunatics or being white.
What is,
what was wrong with this movement that,
that no,
authentically black people seem to be
able to lead it.
I'm like,
there must be this.
Yes,
there's something wrong.
What's wrong with them,
deray?
Dude,
this is promising homosexual.
How dare you.
I might be gay,
but that's still it feel like he is.
He's just so odious and unbearable.
And I loved also,
I loved,
oh,
he's probably the most unlikable person
in America that meets.
What's this?
I don't think he is give these
interviews.
I think he's intelligent and well
spoken.
So nice about everyone except the men
that need you
man up pussies,
pussies.
But deray MCKESSON's great goal.
It's like what's wrong with you?
It seems like a great guy.
I mean,
when I've heard him interviewed
me in a way they're put together with
the bomb,
which were the only black person I w not
sexually attracted to.
Wow.
He,
you say this.
What?
Well,
I mean,
not like,
I mean like I would,
but no,
uh,
I,
I find him so what's wrong?
What are you sort of like sort of
preening comedy,
Homo,
um,
you know,
sort of prancing around in his ones is
that often it's just dreadful,
but he's a product of this terrible
political assumption.
You got to be black and gay in a rights
protester and another,
the black lives matter leaders is white.
And the NAA NAACP chapter heading and
bought in the Washington in Spokane,
in Washington is white.
And I'm thinking to myself,
she resigned on what's wrong with this
movement?
No,
she's still in place.
Or She just resigned from something's
been all,
uh,
I'm thinking to myself,
what's wrong with this movement that no
black people see me?
We're able to lead it.
And the reason is that this is,
as,
this is fueled a source thing,
you know,
it's fueled by,
um,
white guilt and progressive liberal
establishment,
which is incredibly,
one could not exist without,
but he's not a real black is
fuck,
I don't know.
I just said it to annoy people.
I'm getting like,
Twitter is going to be ridiculous now.
I don't even know what I mean by that.
I guess I just don't like the idea that
black people can be homosexual.
I liked,
I liked the idea that everybody's black
guys,
the idea that I'm sort of talking them
out of their heterosexuality for one
night,
you know,
I just,
I think it's all about why I think it's
all about my sort of my doc rape fetish.
Um,
oh,
I just don't know.
I like,
I like just,
I don't like the idea of black people as
homosexuals.
It just feels wrong to me.
You got some fucking issues.
No,
I just have preferences.
I just,
you know,
I like to imagine they're heterosexual.
Gonna have sex versus if you were
involved in potential relationships to
these prophecies of heterosexual black
west to pursue and which ones not to.
This is a man you don't even know.
Oh,
he's an activist and you're like,
I just prefer him to not be gay.
I have a real problem with him being
gay.
I have preferences problem with him
being gay.
I just did it.
He's like gay people.
No,
of course I don't.
Of course I don't.
I love,
I love Dick,
but I hate Larry.
You like hanging out with my people,
all of their fucking Tutus and Madonna
like,
okay,
look,
I have my notes.
I have my moments with my moments with
Mariah Carey.
But um,
but no,
the way they behave,
the music they listened to,
how they dress,
how they speak,
and worst of all,
which really fucking annoys me.
It drives me absolutely crazy the way in
which gay people have now become such
bullies.
They're using all the tools,
um,
against other people or Christians,
the bakeries,
all that kind of shit that used to be
used against them.
Gay people have become the worst kind of
sanctimonious bullies and it makes me
ashamed to be a homosexual when I see
the way that they bully other.
My other minorities,
the way they bully religious minorities.
And I think 50 years ago,
this was gaze.
When I see the way that gay people
brave,
when I see that couple,
that gay couple who went to memories
pizza memory speaks of your,
remember was the,
was the Christian breaker you said?
You know,
probably wouldn't.
We'd rather not Katie wedding if that's
okay because some,
some idiot,
you know,
a troublemaker on the left had gone,
gone basically gone outrage shopping
called up everybody in Indiana.
And so will your Keto when you came to
willow cater,
finally found somebody who said,
I prefer not to anyway.
Is that these days in question admitted
that he,
well,
I think one of the question around are
of going to one day nobody went there
and got turned down and humiliated by
Evil Christians.
A liberal reporter went around shopping
for someone who said no they wouldn't.
And it took them days to anyway,
just like sweet enrolling stays.
She went rate shopping.
Sabrina Erdely admitted that she went
around looking for the most sensational
rape story possible.
And of course it turned out to be
bullshit.
But the [inaudible] hold on.
I'm don't mean to interrupt you,
but I did not know that that was not an
actual story.
The top,
by the way,
it's cooked up by the media.
I thought it was a real gay couples.
This is how I fell into it.
And you know,
and you know what?
The real gay couple,
do you know what Real Cook Gay couples
are doing today?
Well,
this is just,
it just makes me so,
no,
they're not becoming Bosch while they're
getting a car and a kid and a pet.
And then know that not having,
because tiny embers,
no,
they're not all full.
I hate those kind of gaze,
the most of all that terrible.
My delegate,
you should be toppling out of a
nightclub off your tips,
off your tits on ketamine at 4:00 PM on
a Monday afternoon.
Call yourself a homosexual.
You drive a golf like you know,
just stop her range rover but carry on.
Get the kid to school by eight Oh no,
I've got to get back cause I've got
bridge club at 10 just die.
Well he teaches spin class,
crossfit cross soul cycle.
What kind of a self respecting gay
person does soul cycle or bad for you?
Oh Oh all cardio.
Cardio's gay
sex and drugs.
Like any other gay person,
crystal Meth and 12 hour fuck sessions
and they stayed in in the 80s aids news.
Fantastic.
You know,
I'd love if I kind of do want it because
is yeah,
because it's not a death sentence
anymore.
You can't dye your all the great drugs.
But if
you delay taking the drugs,
you get thin,
you lose all your body fat,
you get so much attention or buyer
dollars or the presence when I'm tired
all the time.
Now,
what's the different way more staff?
You're talking so fast.
I don't buy the fact that you're tired
all the time.
It's hard to get a word in edge wise.
You're on fire.
I don't buy the title anyway exhausted.
Just going to finish them sores all over
your face.
You don't want that.
Actually that's not hot,
but it's just the early stages.
But you know like the first,
the first,
the first six months in the bowl or the
first six months of age,
fantastic.
Lose all your body fade your shit all
the way out balls.
You get sores all over your body.
First,
first stage,
first gay couple this week.
And then I promise I'm going to give
this subject up,
but um,
gay couple this week decided to renew
them at renew their wedding vows.
Right?
And they go to memories pizza and they
pick up pizza and they stop parading
around on stage.
How they got memories pizza or they were
doing those nasty Christians who don't
wanna cater gates.
And I thought to myself,
and then the NATO sent these pictures of
the press or whatever,
and I thought said,
what a nasty,
vindictive,
bitter,
soulless way to treat your own wedding
or your vowel renewal or whatever.
Turn it into this triumphalist bitter
public political stumped.
And I thought it was so cheap and so
classless and it represented everything
that's wrong with the gay establishment
today.
And it was just,
I just saw that and I thought,
God,
I hope people don't think that about me
when they know I'm gay,
you know,
um,
this,
these preening bitter,
spiteful,
nasty queers.
And I thought to myself,
in my head,
you fucking idiots.
Like you are doing so much damage to the
public view of homosexuality.
You know,
making people think that [inaudible]
spiteful,
bitter behavior is how we all behave
when we get a taste of power.
Because of course how we judge people.
We judge,
one of the ways we judge people's,
how they behave when they're in power
and now gays or the establishment,
you know,
acquiring gazer power,
look at the disproportionate important,
you know,
a disproportionate numbers of
homosexuals in,
you know,
in employment,
in the media or whatever.
They're constantly fated and
mollycoddled and uh,
and celebrated and all of that is good.
Like the quality is great and you know,
all that's all that's important,
but it's really telling how they behave
when they get to that position.
See this aberration,
this one couple that you're talking
about,
Kim Davis,
the same thing.
The same thing happened to that other
that they know that,
what is it like three or four bakeries
and pizzerias in the u s now the same
thing's happening in Ireland,
in England,
in,
um,
you know,
all over the place.
Gays are becoming bullies and I don't
like seeing it.
I think what's happening is it's you get
a bunch of people who are unhappy that
know that they can have an impact by
doing a something and they know they
have a green while they're obviously on,
I wouldn't behave like this,
but what?
They don't do a something.
Then they're giving you something as we
can protest in this fashion and we will
get a pop.
But they've been given carte blanche to
go after religious minorities because
the,
the media establishment,
politicians,
all the rest of it continually give the
signals.
Are you on Kim Davis Society?
Is that what you're saying?
I mean,
I don't look,
she can't,
she can't do the job right.
She can't do the job.
So she probably shouldn't be in her
posts cause she can't perform the
functions of her job,
her beliefs.
If she refuses to issue those licenses
and that is the law,
right?
She can't be in her job.
But you know what's interesting?
She's these days,
the example of a conscientious objector.
She's an example of somebody sticking up
for their beliefs or their political
opinions or their life or their life
choices or their faith or whatever in
the face of the law,
in the face of public opinion.
And the face of,
um,
you know,
received wisdom,
the consensual,
the rest of it.
She is doing what gate can rights
campaigners were doing 50 years ago.
And I think it's very telling now.
Gay people are mollycoddled and
protected.
And you know,
I've been a beneficiary of that.
I've seen it in action.
Um,
the way that now they can turn around
and bully religious minorities solely to
feel better about themselves in this
horrible bitter way that they do.
Um,
and lesbians the worst by the way.
the way they can now do that to people
who have faith to religious people.
Um,
makes me slightly feel slightly ill and
I'm really,
I really object to it.
Let's slow down.
You're saying that she is doing what
what gay activists were doing 50 years
ago,
which is make brief stands.
They get them in prison to get that go
against the law.
Go against gay activists were never in a
position to alter other people's lives
or deny them of a public service that's
on the books.
See the problem,
which is that she used her own,
she should've never been put in prison,
but you can't compare her to any form of
an act as you can.
How could you possibly do that?
Because she's affecting other people's
lives that have nothing to do with me,
that she shouldn't be in her because she
can't do her job.
While the entire time being guilty of
several sins,
one of them,
the fact that she's being a demo course,
the primary sin of a swinging,
switched out surprised after she still
won't happen.
This is how the Democrats treat their
own well,
and the GOP came and supported and of
course the pneumococcal be flew in a
private jet.
Of course,
the New York Times accidentally
published that she was a Republican.
Of course.
What a terrible Ms Democrat you mean?
No,
no.
They published that.
She was a republican.
Well and there was a normal,
she was a democrat.
It was guilt times.
Just assumed without checking what
you're saying.
Oh,
I said they printed in the newspaper
that she was a republican because I was
the New York Times did and then,
oh sorry.
Made a mistake about that.
And of course no one ever sees the
corrections.
So now every lesson that would fox news
always does.
When someone does something creepy,
they put d next to their name and find
out fair and balanced and they find out
all those really are Republican.
I know,
I love Fox News.
I'm going to say a bad word about Fox
was great.
I think that the gut is good friend
nearly that the comparison is pretty
ridiculous to say that she is doing what
gay activists were doing in the 1950s.
Let's,
but,
um,
from my point of view as somebody who is
both religious and homosexual,
um,
your religious,
yeah,
well,
I mean I saw my,
my match with nearly speaking,
I'm Jewish,
but I was raised Catholic.
Um,
and um,
so does that mean to you practicing in
the middle of ketamine on perfect fuck
sessions?
Yes.
Well that's not very religious.
Shoulder men in dresses.
What's not to love?
If it hadn't been for Michael,
I wouldn't have
made nearly as much money in my
twenties.
He told me to get such good head,
you know,
um,
I gave such good blow jobs off to after
three years in choir.
Um,
no,
I mean,
um,
so you're not religious?
No,
no.
I'm I believe I don't necessarily go to
mass all the time,
but
I'm a Catholic.
We can call it would leave one myself a
catholic.
Yeah,
I'm going to know a good Catholic,
but you know,
but when you say you believe,
like you believe in what the Bible,
I believe in Catholicism.
I'm,
I'm a Catholic.
I think so you believe that it's a good
idea to have confession and you have a,
a dude who never had sex ever listen to
fuck stories whispered through.
Yeah.
Hole in the wall absorbs you cut baby
dicks,
you know,
for,
for for a is very nitpicky turn of dress
like a wizard sitting on the golden
throne.
Right?
We're done.
You have to cut down father.
That all make sense to you.
You know,
want to Catholics.
Well,
do you know what this world could do
with a bit more pomp and circumstance?
A little bit more a drama.
And it could be the man who supports the
fucking matriarchy.
She knew what this work could do.
It could do with it.
A little bit more of that.
I mean,
just look at that.
Look at the dreary hell of the atheist
arts scene.
Look at,
you know,
look at this.
There's some total arts.
My contribution to human searching,
the atheist arts I meet.
What I mean is,
you know,
you still get,
the atheists are seen.
Look at almost all the good movies ever
made.
Look at almost all the great albums ever
Look at almost all the great convenient
told jokes,
pay Hollywood,
atheist,
some biznow.
No,
none.
Comics.
I like if you believe line comedians
contributes to the sum total of human
civilization and knowledge in the way
that anyway,
that Michelangelo did.
I mean Dars,
Oh yes,
Gogh yesterday,
dreary,
awful,
boring herb,
dairy,
all of them that are atheists
totally makes sense.
You need religion to be a good person,
but you especially need rich,
especially in the religion,
to be a good artist,
you need to pick and choose what you do
that you decide is religious and isn't
same as his Kim Davis lady deciding that
the sins of these men were more
important than their own sins or the or.
You.
Would you want to do ketamine and
amphetamines and have just speaking
purely here about five at the age of 13
okay?
These are all not in the Bible all day.
You'll never find hat drag queen
fivesome.
None of the minute
you got to go to the Old Testament.
I think you know you're not.
You're looking at King James on you.
You know,
if you,
if you actually chat,
look at Baltimore.
It's right there in Leviticus.
I read her the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Christian lie with interracial
crossdressing orgies.
You know,
it's,
it's right there.
It's in my,
yeah.
That's the thing though,
isn't it?
Like if you,
if you say you're Christian and you want
to be on that team to kind of say it
Badri veteran than you all aspire to be
better than you are.
It doesn't mean you believe in Jewish
zombies.
We're not going to win this one.
I'm not going to win this one.
Well,
of course,
you know,
this one's ridiculous.
This is ridiculous.
She talking about shit written on animal
skins by people who thought the world
was flat and the sun was 17 miles away
and you're like,
oh yeah,
that's going to make you a better
person.
It's totally,
yeah.
They found it in clay pots and Qumran
yeah,
the,
and scroll,
they had to DNA test to find out which
piece of fucking Yak ass on.
I feel sorry for people who have a sort
of bleak,
empty existence that atheist,
it's just so boring.
Terrible nonsense.
Way to look.
A lack of belief in nonsense is not
bleak.
Do you believe?
Plenty of nonsense.
Like what?
Name one thing?
Uh,
well,
you're so silly.
You've got a silly view on circumcision.
As soon as we've discovered as baby dick
cutting my God,
free agree or disagree,
very nit picky.
You're a hell of a fucking drama queen.
It's an Ab Dick Cutting.
You tell me what it is.
Give tell them what is it.
If it's not baby Dick Cutting,
I'm going to give you just look.
You win.
I'm just gonna give it too much and you
want to brought up the baby.
Didn't cutting.
Call it.
Call it something else.
What is it?
I think it's good grooming.
If aliens from another planet and so I
had cut all the baby Dick's,
they'd be like,
what the fuck are you guys doing?
It's just good.
It's just good grooming.
Okay.
Obviously we disagree.
What other ridiculous shit do I believe
that's a kin to Jewish zombies.
You're taught say off at a water.
There's nothing more depressing than
seeing somebody who you admire who's
obviously smart and clever.
Old Fairy Tales to speak so
disparagingly about such a complex and
fascinating part of who we are.
You're right.
Totally.
Even if you,
even if you take the view,
let's say living flowback,
right?
Even if you take the Foi Bucky end view,
you know,
and say,
I don't believe in any of these
religions say,
okay,
but if we look at what they have in
common and what that says about the
human spirit,
what we aspire to,
what we consider most important.
So for example,
Christianity,
we might consider self sacrifice and
love the most important things because
the,
you know,
self sacrifice and love are the two
central instincts that the red threads
that run through the Christian Canon,
Monster Christian literature run to
Christian history.
That was the most important say is this,
okay?
I don't believe in this stuff,
but this is an essential human,
human artifact of human culture and
history because it teaches us more about
ourselves than anything else,
right?
It teaches us over centuries,
centuries.
This is evolved to teach us what we find
most important and different religions
in different places are fascinating
because they illustrate the different
emphases on those core values of love
and charity and stuff like that.
Different societies place on things.
Now,
I'm not asking you to believe that,
uh,
that when you take holy communion,
you are ingesting the,
you know,
the body and blood of Christ.
That's not going to happen.
But what I am suggesting that you
shouldn't be such a dismissive asshole
about,
you know,
such an integral,
rich,
beautiful and crucial part of human
history that teaches us so much about
who we are.
Okay?
First of all cases a disingenuous
disingenuine sorry,
you were mocking me about [inaudible]
absolutely.
Coming back from the dead healing people
turning wine.
What I'm saying is even if you only
believe their stories,
these are the most important stories
that were the western tradition
symbolization stories,
the most important stories that have
ever been told about folklore.
Even if you believe that they say
something deep and profound about who we
are and about what we care about most,
about our anxieties,
about our beliefs and about our,
um,
you know,
our sympathies,
the way we relate to one another,
the way that that's adorable.
I'm presenting one reason why you should
be less flippant and dismissive about
religion because you are too smart to be
that much of a covenant religion.
I can't believe it's small.
You are far too smart.
You are far too intelligent and
individual to treat religion with the
amount of contempt you do.
This is more assholes too.
This is not what asked mediocre,
mediocre intelligence,
zealots,
APS,
Jews,
feminists of doing distorting the
argument.
What my reality is,
we're talking about myths and we're
talking about Penn.
I'm saved those myths so much that they
won't let people get married because it
goes against their myth.
I'm saying I can disagree with them and
that would happen.
You can disagree with,
you can just pull it right?
Where's the love and the Davis.
You can disagree with everything that
they teach.
You can say that it's nonsense.
You can agree that you can,
if you want to agree that it has bad
consequences in society,
you shouldn't do is ridicule and
dismiss,
you know,
sort of the,
Jewish Zombie Shit,
right?
You're just doing it to be outrageous.
You're just doing what you shouldn't do.
And look,
there was a good
place for it for outrageousness and
provocation.
Right.
And I'm not trying to put you on trial
here,
but I'm saying is you're too smart to
fall into this habit and it's a leftist
thing.
This militant atheism crap or you
dismiss the central importance of
religion to our culture is the central
importance through barbaric days with
rules.
What we worried about the consequences
of God's punishing.
Most of our laws are based on religious
prescription.
When you get down to it,
most of the way society is
organized is based on what's ultimately
religious prescription.
My point is simply and only that if
you're going to be a flippant asshole,
at least acknowledge that first of all,
half the population,
you know,
it does take this stuff seriously.
And second of all,
this is important stuff that tells us
about who we are.
And I think it's beneath you to be so
flippant about it.
It's about feminism because feminism is
not as important.
Stein tells us about flippant and cruel
and vindictive and spiteful and horrible
about crazy feminists because they're
crazy.
And because what they do is ridiculous.
I don't think whether or not you're an
atheist,
that religion is ridiculous and I think
it
deserves a bit more respectful.
Well that's fine.
You're allowed to think of,
but just because you think it doesn't
mean it's right and the idea that it
makes you a flip an asshole because
you're unwilling to accept myths,
you're unwilling to accept things that
make no sense whatsoever.
You're unwilling to accept things that
are
not acknowledging the extent to which
religion has made you who you are.
I mean,
you know from the speech,
the rejection codes that you grow up
with your moral code spaces doesn't mean
stupid.
I didn't say.
That doesn't mean that
what got us to here,
you will see ball,
your senses,
your sense of right and religion,
which was created by people's sense of
right and wrong bull shit
and shit.
And it's interesting he's not come from
that.
That's not very angry.
It's not true.
Your sense of right and wrong comes from
Judy.
You got to stop saying that because it's
not true.
This cultural,
there's right and wrong and other
cultures had to completely different
from what we consider.
Right and wrong in America.
Look in New Guinea.
Do you know what about the sperm
warriors in New Guinea?
These men that take these young boys
when they're young and inseminate them,
put common their mouths and their acids
to make them grow.
They do that from the time they have
like,
isn't that great?
It's their culture.
It's,
it's what's right and what's wrong for
them.
Things that would be absolutely illegal
would lock you up in jail for in America
and in Europe,
in New Guinea.
This is a great long tradition of this
part and then out your day a Christians.
It's cultural.
Yes,
exactly.
Christian cultures,
many things that you have good values
that I agree with the call Shit Bullshit
for me,
I just made it.
You grew up in a basis.
Christianity.
You're a good person.
This place where there's no
Christianity,
they come and boys mouths.
There's one place that has a fucked up
way of looking at things.
It's a cultural thing.
It doesn't have it everywhere.
That doesn't have a strong Christian.
Heritage is a fucked up place with bad
with bad morals.
That's a ridiculous statement.
That's a ridiculous statement everywhere
that doesn't have jail,
Judeo Christian values,
a fucked up place.
I think that,
yes,
I think,
I think you should be perfectly
reasonable respectful thing to say our
culture is better.
I believe our culture is better than the
culture of Christian European shares,
Ketamine,
Ph,
other European and American culture,
which is based on Judeo Christian values
is better than other cultures.
I think it's uncontroversial to say so,
but what's what,
based on Judeo Christian values about
being a good person,
ultimately all us from the Bible,
what it does,
what comes from the Bible.
Ultimately our sense of right and wrong
comes to the Bible,
our sense of,
right.
I think you also see the only way that a
person could have ethics and morals and
treat each other.
I wouldn't say the
Pacific.
Listen,
if we're going to have a conversation,
we can't keep talking over each other
like this.
When someone's trying to make
a point about something that's complex
like this,
if you're,
if you think that the only way for a
person to have ethics or an
understanding of each other or
compassion for each other is to rely on
ancient myths that are easily,
scientifically disproven.
Well,
that's what Christianity is.
No,
I didn't say that.
That's what the Bible said.
This is the specific set of values that
you have is influenced more than you
would like to admit by your Judaic
Christian influenced by
all of us.
Have,
I mean,
look,
I think that some,
some of what we would call morality
obviously comes from natural revulsion,
which is more like biological,
right?
Then this is,
this is some of the prescriptions
against perhaps against murder,
perhaps against child abuse,
that kind of stuff.
Right?
It comes from instead of natural
revulsion and it may be an evolutionary,
biological imperative.
There's certain things that we just know
we shouldn't do.
Right.
And that's our body's saying no,
like,
you know,
like the smell of rotten food.
You know,
it was stuff like that.
Yeah.
Um,
but there are other things that,
um,
the definitely come from the,
from the Judaic Christian tradition has
defined most of what we consider to be
right and wrong in the west.
And I think our society is the better
for it.
Uh,
and I think that our society is better
than elsewhere in the world.
And your lifestyle is proof positive
that that's the evolution of what this
used to be or what it is today.
Early speaking,
I'm an outlier because I mean,
as you know,
gay people generally test hire for Iq
than the rest of the population and lots
of evolutionary biologists and we'll
suggest that that gate people with high
Iq is tend to engage in,
um,
uh,
dissident or unusual habits and
practices in general because that's
where,
um,
where mother nature does her
experimentations,
where she tests the limits of,
of,
um,
of the species.
So people with very high Iq are more
likely to be homosexual goes the
evolutionary biology argument because
it's in those very smart people that the
sort of the,
the transgression and transgressive
dissidents stuff has tried out by mother
nature.
So I would say I'm probably an outlier.
There is a very small homosexual.
Um,
you know I'm not typical of of sort of
mainstay of,
of of the kind of bulk of the species.
Right.
But what you are,
I mean I might take it to whoever you
are but who you are being a gay man who
I am,
what I do that is this right here but it
in the Bible.
Yes,
but I agree that it would be better if I
didn't behave like this and if I could
[inaudible] homosexual.
No.
And I wouldn't have this you need to
read is wonderful essay by Bernice.
I don't need to read shit.
What the fuck you're saying.
Okay.
So goes what you're saying is who you
are is prohibited in the bylaw because I
don't think my sexuality is an important
component part of you.
You talk about it all the time.
It's a massive part of what we've talked
about on this show I think comes up
anytime you want to make a funny point.
It comes up anytime you want to do malty
or your urges or do well on a few.
I think people,
I think it's you,
what I think people leap to the most,
uh,
the most different thing about
themselves,
the most unusual thing about themselves.
Anytime they want to be funny or be,
um,
you know,
it's black versus white.
Black comedians talk about being black a
lot.
Chris rock always talks about,
you know,
blacks and inward.
Um,
it's why,
uh,
you know,
Muslim comedians only ever talk about
Islam.
It's,
you know,
gay comedians talk about being gay.
I think that's,
you go to that because it's the most
different funny thing about you.
It's,
and it's a sort of,
sort of a form of laziness I suppose.
Um,
so I don't know that's particularly
relevant,
but,
uh,
I'll wait.
Listen,
it's absolutely relevant.
Make it bounce to the jokes and a lot of
cultures and Muslim culture is not going
to use no announced.
Um,
and it's,
it's any of them.
It's in the Muslim world that does that.
Now.
11 countries continue the grand old
tradition of killing gay people.
But that shit's been around forever.
I mean,
what does it say in the Bible about a
man lying with another man?
I think if I could,
I mean,
if I could change,
if I could choose,
I wouldn't be homosexual.
That doesn't make me self loathing.
So if someone came out and it just made
me so Pfizer came out with a pill to
make me,
no,
it doesn't.
No,
it doesn't make you self loathing to
hate a part of what you are a part of
what I am.
I love all of me,
but if I could choose to be even better,
then I would be.
So you'd be better if you were straight?
Yes.
Wow.
Anybody would be,
if Johnson would be better if he was
strong and had an anti gay pill.
Yeah,
you would take it.
What?
It would be curious suicide,
but I probably would.
Yeah.
Would it be career suicide?
You don't think that you could
transition into the straight world?
You would be the poster boy for
Christian.
Right?
They would love you.
Tru,
you know,
if I were to pray the gay away,
I'd be so popular.
Super popular.
That's what's holding you back is the
gay.
You're right.
Maybe that's,
you're intelligent.
You're good looking.
You're well dressed.
It's true.
You're right.
Okay.
I'm going to,
I'm going to enroll in one of these
camps again.
I'm going to cheat.
I'm going to get out the work.
They just an excuse for Denise,
like Michele Bachmann's husband.
You ever heard about the camp that that
guy was running?
That guy's the greatest or Oregon after
hours.
How about you say that,
but hold up.
We'll bring that back.
But how about the guy that got arrested?
Hillary fucking people at that,
uh,
that community center killer.
Then often many cases,
serial killers.
I was like,
no,
he's a KKK guy that got arrested with
black prostitutes.
Oh yeah,
of course he did.
Of course he did.
Of course.
He's my favorite course.
I love it.
They're out of the grace of God.
Go on.
Um,
so my favorite guys,
people who get caught with black
prostitutes,
I mean literally could,
could be me on any first aid,
the racist murderers to get caught with
blackboard.
Those are adorable.
I didn't mean at first,
but as long as you don't have to have
direct contact with anybody,
they affected.
It's an adorable story.
No,
obviously I don't,
there was a guy look at him.
Ah,
and you just know that he had like these
big black girls whipping him and like
raping him with,
um,
you know,
with a Dildo and stuff.
You just know that when he was a male
sub men,
male prostitutes see black male
prostitutes Mandingo thing,
didn't he?
There's a lot going on there.
It,
I just can't believe that you would,
uh,
you would decide to not be gay if you
could.
And is that because of Christian values?
No,
no,
no.
So what is it?
Uh,
I,
I don't think it's self loathing to
acknowledge that being homosexual is
obviously a sort of aberrant sexuality.
It's something that Mother Nature does
on the fringes and nobody really knows
why.
And it could be,
you know,
elegant variation and the evolutionary
process.
It could be all sorts of things.
Who knows the variation,
the,
something like that.
Uh,
from a Christian perspective,
it could be a test from the evolutionary
perspective.
It could be a Christian perspective.
Some Christians believe that you get
these things in life as tests and they
don't judge the sinner.
They judge the sin and what they mean by
that is you can be gay,
but if you act on it,
that's when you become sin so they don't
stay.
Don't blame you for who you are.
They believe me,
they wonder what you'll do is bullshit.
You're gay is fun.
Presenting the argument,
dude,
fuck,
okay.
There's not a God damn choice in the
world for you other than being gay.
Well you're the perfect example of this
shit,
this shipping nonsense that it's a
choice that somehow or another you're
presented [inaudible]
you're on.
You're on that because I'm actually born
this way is an invention of the gay
lobby.
Once you go back to the
science for this,
as you guys know base,
there is a broad spectrum.
There is nice.
Actually what I'm going to be very
specific because I know you like
specificity.
There is no basis in science for the
born this way argument.
There's no basis in science that you are
simply born gay and that's all there is
to it.
What the science suggests is that it is
very much nature and nurture and it can,
it's as much as 50,
50 in nature and nurture.
Right?
The gay lobby in the 1980s was worried
about,
as I finish this one,
the gay lobby in the 1980s was worried
because religious people were saying
that the gay lifestyle lifestyle,
it was a sinful choice,
right?
So they came up with this thing in the
gay gene and it is an invention of the
gay lobby designed to get around
religious bigots.
It's designed to,
um,
to wrong foot to the religious right and
suggest that people's sexuality has no,
there's no element of choice and people
sexuality born this way.
You're hearing lady Gaga Song and we
take it as good as,
as granted as you obviously had no idea
that it was even real until you just
said the lady Gaga was born this way.
Uh,
one of her biggest hits,
never heard of it.
Indeed.
Uh,
one of her biggest hits is based on an
invention.
The gala with no basis in science.
What the science says is it's a mixture.
So it simply isn't true to say that you
know,
you're just born gay and that's all
there is to it.
For most people it is a mixture of early
environmental factors and natural
predisposition.
That's the most we can say that's the
most,
that's with any confidence and with any
surety,
that's the most that we can say from the
available science born this way is a
marketing gimmick.
It doesn't mean anything.
Okay.
But when you say that you're,
you're talking about,
again,
a broad spectrum of human sexuality.
So some people come part going to be
much more nurturing.
Some people it's going to be much more
nature are born gay.
There's a fucking kid that lives down my
street,
he's five years old and he's gay gaze.
Fuck,
okay,
you might like to play with Asian man,
but he doesn't necessarily,
he's not necessarily gonna be gay.
And I have a problem with you ascribing
sexuality to a five year old boy because
that's exactly what the transgender
parents do.
That's exactly when the transgender
parents say,
my five year old was really supposed to
be a girl.
You're doing exactly the same thing
you're saying he's five years old.
He hasn't even hit puberty yet.
He has no idea who he is.
No idea what he's going to believe.
No idea who is going to want to fuck
when he's older.
He's nowhere near puberty and your
saying this kid is gay.
You are doing exactly the same thing as
these Canadian parents who say that my
five year old girl should be a boy.
Please give them hormones.
You'd be exactly the same.
Certainly not.
I'm certainly not because I don't want
to give anybody hormones and I don't
want to influence this guy's life in any
way so I'm going to hang back and watch
fucking apologize.
I will come back to you in 10 years.
I will come back on this show.
You get him on cause his mom calls him
go well his mum is wrong and his mom,
his mom is just random everyday
Schweppes his ass.
She might know he's gay.
She knows all the things say is up
there.
She's not a bad person.
She's finding things he's put up.
There are all black dicks.
She doesn't say it in a in a bad way.
She just said she's just pretty sure
he's gay.
You know what actually think he's seven
now.
I don't particularly like that line of
argument.
Ascribing sexualities.
People that haven't even hit puberty
yet,
it seems a bit much to me.
You'd think that with a lot of people
they are gay.
I mean Jen is just what they are
with you.
Some people.
No,
no.
I'm definitely for you made a choice.
Definitely 50 50 50 50 so you're well
aware of the fact that there is an
element of deliberation in my sexuality
and that's one of the things that annoys
me about the establishment gay left
where they insist born this way is on
placards and banners and the Texas,
the taxpayers,
some but a minority,
a minority of people have no choice over
their sexuality.
Out of the,
out of the total number of gay people in
minority have no have no choice
whatsoever.
Nobody else.
There is a varying amount of choice.
I am aware that there was a degree of
deliberation and my sexual orientation,
yet I am forced through my taxes to pay
for gay pride banners that say born this
way.
It's just something that you are,
yeah,
I mean like the way that gay pride stuff
is,
is financed by the taxpayer in England.
Right.
It's given,
given money by the government.
My taxes go to gay pride.
People who tell lies in the street stuff
that I know isn't true.
Medu it basically to get people and they
do it in the same bitter,
nasty way that paid for a sign that just
said it's okay to be gay.
Would you be cool though?
They do that too and I'm fine with that.
Yeah,
sure.
I don't want my taxes,
my taxes to pay for it.
Uh,
I definitely said born this way and then
the asterick some small percentage.
Well that would be your kind of,
that will be your dreary pick a side,
some people that gay comma and then
you'd have like a paragraph of text.
You know,
you wouldn't actually be able to see it
from very far away,
but your,
your version of this gift,
this born this way sign.
We'd be like,
let me start with this online in some
circumstances be bought.
Do you see this?
You see the problem now you to see the
problem now,
but I'm objecting.
I'm just
is simply telling people lies born this
way is a lie and true story with some of
them.
Nobody that's holding the signs because
most of the ones holding the signs,
the militant homosexuals are the ones
that chose to be gay to get it.
People gays.
Does she uh,
do,
do you have like debates with gay people
about their sources?
My skates wanting to debate me because
they know they'll lose.
Well they've got woman brains.
Don't worry.
Get logic brains.
I'm just kidding.
You accuse me trolling out here.
So I thought I better do it to live up
to the reputation.
Certainly do.
And you're also very aware that uh,
you,
you are right wing views and the,
there was right,
right.
Kind of a little bit of a right wing Ben
to you.
You talk about conservatives and dressy
events to wear a suit and tie this,
this right?
Like a good way to align yourself in the
club is you have to espouse Christian
values or talking about being Christian.
Give us stuff about what the
conservative establishment thinks of me.
If I did,
my career would have turned out very
differently.
I've,
I,
you know,
I would have chosen a very different
path through my professional life.
You know,
I was at the Telegraph and it,
you know,
the,
the most respectable establishment
newspaper in England,
uh,
eight years ago if I'd want it to be,
you know,
a sign on of the,
of the conservative Republican
establishment.
I could've done that.
I did the exact opposite.
I've stuck my nose up and my middle
finger up at conservatives every
available opportunity.
I bright,
poor,
poor Breitbart who put up with so much
from me.
You know,
they published Black Dick Jokes every
week from me and that is a direct
assault on the kind of stomach churn
that the conservative writers or West
set to have about gay things.
Right?
I don't just tell them I'm gay.
I tell them I'm sucking Black Dick,
right?
Really good columns to be funny and
entertaining and I'm right to
everything.
And it also puts them in a very
interesting place where they can say,
look,
we have a gay guy working for us.
I tend to think probably about gives us
stuff about whether people think that
homophobic on all.
They certainly wouldn't hire me.
The second is everybody.
Everybody does trust me,
trust me.
Right.
But doesn't care about,
doesn't care if they're not,
but they don't care if you do.
Right.
What they care about is the facts of
what they published and the facts,
what they probably should,
but most of the time I see so strange is
someone who believes but doesn't
practice.
You believe in religion,
but you don't practice any of the things
that that religious spouses,
especially the sexual of the things,
but what do you practice that religion?
I do most of the 10 Commandments.
It's steel.
I don't go,
we don't cover the wives.
No.
I mean I probably covered your wife's
toxin,
but
you see what I'm saying?
Most of
the 10 Commandments.
I saw that on most of the 10
Commandments.
I except for the gay stuff
that's in the book though.
God is gonna go.
It's gonna look after me.
You know,
I've got a,
I've got a first class ticket to heaven.
Well,
you know the Moses Come Commandments,
the angels,
Jerusalem scholars now believe that
Moses was high on drugs.
You know that,
right?
I'm sure you've read
that.
I guess another thing we have in common
that Moses,
and you don't have any,
but yeah,
I think it was on different drugs,
pills or something.
Back then it was acacia.
I just be strictly accurate.
I have not admitted to anything but the
bird,
the idea is the idea that the burning
Bush was a Bush that was a high and
concentrated dod like a k.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And that's nice on some kind of awesome
pause.
Very powerful psychedelic.
Well,
this is Steve Job says he has these
visions of divine inspiration on Lsd,
which has enabled him to these very
different than dimethyltryptamine.
No,
dimethyltryptamine is a visionary
hallucinogen extremely powerful one.
That's the what?
IOWASCA that's the active ingredient and
Iowasca yeah.
Idea is that,
that's what Moses was doing.
That,
that's why the burning Bush,
the literal translation of what that
episode it was your smoking DMT.
He's getting a DMT trip and that's why
God is giving him these ideas about how
people should behave and be,
you know,
what,
what is divine,
you know,
to be kind to each other to have a view
on that.
But um,
I suppose it does sound like the
product.
If somebody on a nice trip,
well these are mainstream scholars.
They really nice to everyone.
Moon.
Just like,
don't fuck you.
Don't fuck someone else's.
Whoa dude steel.
I carved it out.
I mean,
you'd have to be quite high on drugs to
build,
but back then they carved down any idea
that they had.
They didn't really have any other
options.
I couldn't make billboards.
The state have to pay for it.
The Christianity result of a drug trip.
I haven't had something today that is a,
what some mainstream scholars believe
this day.
I have.
I have,
I think,
I think I'm right in saying that.
I sort of semi read that somewhere and I
didn't follow it up,
but I will,
I will look into that.
I'm sure you have.
Well,
you know John Marco Allegro,
the guy who was one of the,
uh,
head scholars that was deciphered the
Dead Sea Scrolls after 14 years of
studying.
He was a ordained minister,
but he was also agnostic because he
starts studying religion,
realized it was all bullshit,
but he wrote a book called the,
the sacred mushroom and the cross that
he believes that the entire origins of
Christianity was based around fertility
rituals and the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms fast.
That does sound fascinating.
Book,
obviously Bolex but it does sound fun at
all.
I mean,
he's,
he was a well renowned religious
scholar.
It does.
A guy who understood language,
he actually trace back the word Christ
to an ancient Sumerian word that meant a
mushroom covered in God's seaman.
She mean the psychedelic mushrooms that
grew out of nowhere.
They thought that when it rained,
it was God coming on the earth and that
these mushrooms that would come up and
then they would eat them and have these
great trips,
they thought they were experiencing God.
And you can,
you can,
um,
you can generate quite a few
extraordinary,
um,
theories with etymology because 70 words
sound like so many other words.
So it sounds like an interesting thought
experiment and Nice Social Studies
paper,
but I'm not sure I quite buy it as a
explaining.
Never looked into it.
But if you do look into it,
you gotta you gotta assume that we'll
look into,
I'll write about it.
Fascinating.
Spectacular psychedelic experiences
would be interpreted by the people who
had no science,
no books,
no,
no knowledge of what's going on with the
human neuro chemistry as being something
that was divine you.
If you had no other reference point
sending right about that.
Yeah,
I mean,
I wouldn't say there's lots of things.
There's always things about life in
general that would be considered
miraculous.
I mean the Sun rising childbirth,
I'm sure there's lots of things that we
can,
all those things attributed to the gods.
And when these people were on these
incredibly powerful psychedelic drugs,
they would try to hide this knowledge
from the Romans.
And so they hid these stories and
parables.
It's a really fascinating,
and by the way,
very controversial thing because
religious scholars you,
you don't say,
well it's,
this is why one of the reasons why is he
was the only one who was an agnostic who
was on the Dead Sea Scrolls to ciphering
committee,
all the other ones where it was really,
he was an ordained minister,
but he wasn't practicing.
All the rest of them were very
religious.
And so the interpretations that they
were willing to accept where not what he
was willing to accept.
So you would have to get someone of that
level of understanding of the language
to,
to debate him on this and what,
I know he's dead,
but it's Catholic church,
but out the book you can buy it now,
but it's like a,
well now it got republished a few years
ago by this guy named John Irvin and you
so you can get ahold of it now,
but for the longest time we still have
to buy it as a used book.
Well,
I will look it up.
Yeah.
This one also the Dead Sea Scrolls,
the Christian myth,
he wrote a second one after the Catholic
Church bought out.
The first one stopped production of it
and bought out all the books.
Yes,
your people.
Catholics.
I tried to hide that information.
We're great at pl.
They last thing they want.
I went to Catholic school,
man for a whole year.
Cured me,
wakes me up.
Good.
It's where you get you a fine sense of
right and wrong from no wait,
let's not do that.
Well what's right and wrong as far as
what anyone's right,
what is wrong now I got lucky.
They beat me a little smack me a little
bit.
Lucky you didn't get that taste of no,
I said just like I said earlier,
if it went from Father Michael,
I would have given far less good head.
I mean,
there was a real father Michael,
so much less than he's going to get
killed now,
but who was father Michael?
There's a real dude I should've made me
suck his dick for real.
Um,
I make me,
I was going to ask you about it.
I thought my English teacher too,
but how old was he at the time?
Um,
I don't know.
She's quite young.
Quite cohort.
Really?
Yeah.
And so that's where it all started.
The Father Michael?
No,
no,
it was that post the tranny.
Yeah,
it was posted.
So it wasn't like I wasn't drag queens a
child or anything like that.
So,
uh,
it was quite a,
you already had the five.
So when like this is all wrong,
I need to talk to father Michael.
He's like,
suck my Dick and shut the fuck up.
And you're like,
religion is,
I really,
I really had no hope.
Did I?
I was,
I was never going to end well.
Well it seems like you kept stumbling in
a Dick's pulling on them through life.
I don't know what would have happened if
a heterosexual man that he is,
I've just been falling on decks.
Was in the same circumstances as you
early on.
I mean obviously things would have went
very different,
so I'm not sure if I buy the not,
you'd go down great.
And the gay club go down.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
we have an expression you go down well,
so go down what it means you would,
you'd be popular.
You got your attention.
Would be like the way you would describe
a meal or a drink.
Oh,
like it goes down.
Well,
yeah.
So No.
Um,
we like taking the piss.
Yeah.
Took me a while to get,
what the hell do you want?
A Cup of mine?
Yeah.
Which,
which again is another thing.
Gay people seem disproportionately into
their appeal on each other.
That seems to be a water sports.
So what does the Lord,
I'm saying only gay to be transgressive.
They choose to be
changed to be gay,
to be naughty now being a homosexual
place.
I know Gail.
I just can't full Blair myself away.
Can't tear myself away.
As you get older and you know,
she'd drive dries up.
I think I would have made a good priest.
Do you think I'm making a good priest?
I think a bit.
Well,
you make a good priests.
If you think the guy that made you suck
his dick was a good priest.
That kind of,
he was a great priest.
Honesty,
like he was good.
Other than that,
I've never had a better senior tutor.
He was great singing teacher got notes
out of me.
I didn't even know I could produce while
he worked.
Your plumbing shattering,
the chandelier's kind of,
but was he good outside of what he did?
Like was he a good religious scholar?
Was he a good parish priest?
I mean,
I just see she can creep getting his
Dick sock then it's going to get lynched
now.
How's it going to get lynched?
Does people,
do people know who he is?
I didn't think so.
What's his name?
Well,
I'm not saying anymore.
I will be you.
At the time you were a little kid and he
was like,
what?
You're just trying.
You're trying to,
was he in his twenties or thirties?
Yes.
Another feminist strategy that you have
adopted in addition to your language,
but he says he's trying to turn header
files.
I told you it wasn't the pedophilia.
I was teens.
I was in my teens,
14 I was in my teens,
something like that.
Something like that.
Pedophilia,
buddy.
I don't know how the rocket,
and I was very old England.
I was in my teens.
I'm hearing a my country and never,
never seen a 15 year old girl at any
point in your life,
however old you are,
you've never seen a 15 year ago we
thought was off when I was 15 no,
dude,
when you were 25 when you were 13 girls,
about 15 you thought,
whoa,
whoa.
No,
you did a dental books should be
hopping.
I didn't want to fucker bullshit.
Shut it off.
You can't tell me what I was born into.
I think if you're 14 you're born this
way.
You're born a dreary nit picker.
Oh,
you're trying to make it so I'm a
fucking creeper like you.
I'm not,
I'm not in the 14 year olds.
How dare you know?
He's a 14 year old fucking,
the guy that you said is a great guy.
He was in a 14 year old stick.
Terrible person.
No,
surely when I was a very mature 14 year
old.
Yeah.
Well,
in your case,
he got it right.
You've got the right guy to molest.
It wasn't molestation and that's
absolutely,
most of the station is perfectly
consensual.
I don't think it is when they're 14 when
I was 14 trust me,
I was the predator.
I was the Predator,
the Predator chasing after the crease.
He's trying to stay close to God,
seeing everybody I was,
I was aggressively seeking out sexual
company of adults because I knew it
would horrify people because I wanted
sort of power over them.
It was my way of rebelling,
my way of rebelling.
I was,
I was the Predator of 14 let me tell
you,
do you think that's what's going on with
that guy who directed x men?
Bunch of Bryan singer,
a bunch of 14 year old predators.
Yeah.
After that.
Poor man.
I,
I'm not sure it's the case with him.
No,
that's a guy know I lived in Hollywood a
while ago briefly.
And did you go to one of his parties?
I went to other people who I won't name
of a similar stature in Hollywood.
I went to the both parties into their
house parties and things and some of the
things I have seen,
it beggars belief.
Yeah.
Can you give us like a,
well,
just,
I can't,
I don't want to be indiscreet about
specific people because I think it's
going to dance around the facts.
Yeah.
Dangerous.
But I can tell you the truth without
dropping anyone in it.
Okay.
And some of the boys that were very
young,
very young,
I don't necessarily remember,
no,
no.
Like,
I don't know,
eight years ago,
um,
I don't,
I don't remember
whether I ever met Bryan singer or
whatever or even knew who he was then.
But I knew other people of similar
stature,
as I say.
And there were some very young boys
around at that time.
There was a lot of drugs and a lot of,
a lot of twinks taking drugs and having
unsafe sex with older men.
And some of these boys were very young,
desperate,
desperate for a job.
You know,
when Andy Cohen,
the Guy Runs Bravo,
had apologize for the use of the word
twink apologize for Twain.
I thought that was one of the most
adorable things.
Gay,
gay as fuck.
And he said the word twink and he had to
apologize because what?
Cause it was demeaning to somebody
starts,
someone was like a perfect twink and he
made like a social media comment.
Nothing.
Nothing's wrong with that.
I got you.
See this,
this is the thing you see,
the progressive's are starting to police
homosexuals lang.
You know,
I've got this theory right.
Um,
I believe that,
um,
pedophilia is the next progressive
rehabilitation drive.
But I also think that straight,
sorry,
that homosexual white guys are going to
be put back into the establishment
bucket very soon.
If you look at some of the whining
editorials coming out was like the daily
beast,
um,
this female female columnist and the
daily beast who will,
who will publish things about seeing it
on your Grindr profile,
this app that you use to pick up guys
nearby,
which is best just to see if torsos and
you just pick or you want to get fucked
by
its correct.
Jesus would've planned that.
I feel like the iPhone and I don't use
it for that reason,
not for that reason.
I don't use these.
I don't need to.
Um,
but uh,
on that,
um,
on the APP,
some people say whites only.
Some people say only Hispanics.
People just express their sexual
preference.
Everybody has a sexual preference.
It's perfectly reasonable.
But of course,
you know,
there's some progressive column is just
finally like five years later as
cottoned onto this and decided to make a
thing about it and said,
problematic that gay people express
racial preferences in dating.
Of course it isn't.
We will have the Okcupid data actually
shows us which racism,
which genders,
um,
you know,
come out on top and come out of the
bottoms like Asian women do very well,
black women really badly.
Um,
you know,
and the sort of league tables of,
of of hotness a minimum.
Anyway.
Um,
so the sign to police the language now
and there's police,
the sexuality of homosexuals.
I mean there was me thinking we were
sliding dangerously close to tolerance
and understanding and now progressive's
are starting to police the sexuality of
homosexuals again.
Um,
very interesting.
There's a game of Gotcha though.
It's a chemo scarred shirts so they
don't really,
they're not really upset that they're
not upset.
They're looking for something to
complain about.
But the problem with the prom with
outrage culture,
I mean,
I've always said the only part where
age,
culture is what it is,
right.
And the problem without any way to
approach outrage culture,
which is what I do,
is to be outrageous,
right?
Say Ridiculous and outrageous things
simply to draw attention to the people
to get upset about it.
I think it's a very important project
and it's what I do in a lot of my
columns.
That's what I do on Twitter.
I've done it a little bit today.
Um,
and I think it's very important to wait
a minute.
You've done a little bit of it today.
I've been outrageous.
Haven't said anything I believe,
but I've been outrageous.
Going to read you something outrageous,
little bit outrageous.
Um,
just a little bit.
I've turned myself down for you.
Cause I know,
can heterosexual lump lumping Cretia
threatened me?
No,
I've,
I've taken,
I've toned myself down with you today,
but,
um,
no,
I,
I very,
very firm believer that the only
appropriate response to outreach culture
is to be outrageous.
But the problem with outreach culture is
that,
uh,
because these people are all basically
quite thick,
um,
they tend to move in herds and so
outreach culture can have,
um,
trends,
you know,
and so,
uh,
people can sort of cottoned onto a
particular idea and suddenly everybody's
outraged about the same thing.
And I see ahead of us,
um,
sort of policing of the culture of
heterosexual gay men,
heterosexual,
gay,
sorry.
Sorry,
Sorry.
Of of white gay men.
Um,
on the basis that they have,
uh,
almost like the ultimate male privilege,
you know,
they're not there.
They are smarter and richer and better
looking and Saskia and,
uh,
all the things that feminists hate
because feminists are none of those
things as feminists are
disproportionately poor and ugly and
unlovable.
Um,
and uh,
and they disproportionately poor.
Yes.
Because,
well,
because the liberals
put me in a poor,
ugly,
miserable,
broken people are much more likely to
become liberal.
What's the percentage that don't have a
natural hair color?
Oh,
close to a hundred.
Do you know,
do you know I've got,
I went to this,
I went to the salon today and I said,
Gee,
I'm going on.
I'm waiting on this show.
I think it'd be really funny if you gave
me like blue hair cause we can make a
joke out of it.
And he just looked at me and went,
no,
you're too handsome guys.
18 eight on Santa Monica.
Um,
no,
I thought it was nice.
That gave me a lot spring in my step.
That's beautiful.
No,
I'm not doing that to you.
You're too good looking.
I really know.
It's adorable.
I know.
I tips huge.
Which I guess was the point.
I guess it was the point he was,
he was gunning for.
Um,
he also gave me my first,
you'll appreciate this as a real man.
Um,
he gave him my first ever cutthroat
shave.
Oh,
well,
it's one of those straight razors.
Yeah.
I've never had it done before.
I felt like I became a man today.
Real men don't do that because you don't
trust a man with a fucking razor blade.
You don't need because you've got it.
There's no,
there's no maneuver where you can get
it.
Yeah.
You don't want it like a martial art.
There's no,
she's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Where there was a guy,
I believe it was in San Diego that just
slit someone's throat for no reason.
Just went crazy and just went crazy.
Yeah.
And they arrested him.
The person lived though,
but they're fucked up.
I,
they have surgery and like,
he's a guy just sliced open their
throat.
I was petrified that he would slip or
that someone would make him jump or
somebody would just come in the store.
It's like turning around and get
earthquakes here.
Cut My throat open,
you know,
they can just get a razor.
I watched San Andreas earthquake,
so I watched San Dress on a plane over
what happens to San Francisco is just
awful really?
And so dress.
Yeah,
it's just terrible.
It's awful to see San Francisco brain
when you watch that movie is even worse.
I like him.
What's his name?
Yeah,
he's great.
He's awesome.
I'm a fan actually.
I've seen pretty much everything he's
been in.
And do you know what that movie,
he's actually kind of good actor in
that,
like he's quiet,
but like with this stuff with his
daughter at the beginning when the mom's
moving into the house with the new guy
who did the boss did,
he runs away.
Motherfucker,
I need your phones away and leaves her
in the course.
He does pussy.
What happens when probably British acts
pretty it.
British actor.
They're always about going male feminist
palsy.
Probably male feminist.
Yeah.
Uh,
and um,
no,
and I thought his acting was subtle.
I thought it was really point.
I thought it was a great performance,
but it was great.
It was great.
I can do everything you want.
It's pretty cool.
That movie sucked.
I just liked seeing San Francisco,
like pummeled with waves,
too many games,
natural disasters,
the solid self hate that you could be.
You could be,
you,
you'd like to be there in an orgy when
the big one hits God,
take me away.
Well,
maybe taking another way of earthquakes.
Tsunami,
San Francisco.
So all evil in America that comes in
your butt tsunami takes you away.
I've never been propelled forward by it.
Not yet.
Yeah.
First time for everything.
Maybe we,
I dunno,
you're in San Francisco,
so yeah,
that's how we do it though.
Some street fat you'd get propels and I
think get repelled.
Just the viral load that's inside that
person's body.
Boom.
I always wanted to just have days at t
on tap in the hipster bars in San
Francisco for the ECT.
Really worked.
That was like the big conspiracy.
That AZT was a cancer medication,
that they were using an aids when they
thought it was the gay cancer.
They stopped AZT a long,
long,
long time ago.
My,
so much so that there was a kindness,
my gauge of sort of like 80s bigotry.
I'm totally,
I'm totally out of date or my gay hate.
There was a guy named Peter though
I had him on the podcast and Mandy's
very few people I've ever had on the
podcast that brought so much hate with
them.
But yeah,
he is a biologist at the University of
California,
Berkeley,
uh,
tenured fucking professor up there who,
believed that HIV did not cause aids and
that what HIV was,
was a weak virus that,
uh,
only existed in the bodies of people
that already had compromised immune
systems.
And he said the correlation between
partying and a party drugs,
crystal meth dream and all this
different shit.
This is what drives you into the eye.
It's just what could crushes your immune
system.
It's really amazing.
Academics believe we have this
extraordinary reverence for science and
of course we do,
right?
Yeah.
Because it's what tells us mostly about
how the world works.
Python I've see from,
you know,
the transcendental bits that are
actually met her.
Uh,
but it tells us,
it tells us so much about how the world
functions,
you know,
like what's going to happen if I do
that?
Uh,
you know,
science tells us all these things,
right?
And,
um,
so we have this,
I suppose,
appropriate reverence for scientists,
but what we always forget is just how
mentor and fallible and in many cases
unintelligence then many of them are.
Yeah.
Oh,
there people,
they vary so widely to change stuff.
You know,
dark secret that I never tell anyone,
which I'm going to reveal to you.
You don't believe in climate change.
Oh No,
no.
I'm perfectly happy,
but I haven't even met McClemmits first
motherfucker.
No,
I don't believe in manmade climate
change at all.
But you don't know.
You don't believe in it?
No,
I don't think it's,
I don't think,
I don't think we are affecting the
climate significantly.
No,
no,
no.
So all those scientists,
they don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
Well,
this is my dark secret.
So for two years,
nobody knows this.
I'm going to lose.
I'm going to,
this is going to be the,
my last shred of conservative
credibility.
Gone off to this show.
I worked for a climate change NGO.
Uh,
and um,
I saw at the u I went to the UN,
I was in the front row for Al Gore
speech host in Barley,
let,
all the UN stuff.
I went to all their events and I saw
firsthand just what a load of what a
crock of shit.
So much of it is really,
I mean,
look,
we now know the IPC reports in the UN
are total horse shit.
Lead authors are asking for the names to
be removed from them now because they've
turned into just into ideological
political documents.
They have no basis in climate science
whatsoever anymore.
But even in the early days when,
uh,
when they were supposedly better,
I saw,
um,
papering over of data.
I was asked to do it and I didn't.
I saw,
um,
people emitting,
uh,
data sets that didn't fit with the,
with the,
um,
uh,
hypotheses.
I saw people getting reports,
some scientists,
and rewording them to make them more
extreme and more alarmist.
I saw all of this happened,
um,
and I saw all this happen in multiple
organizations whose sole purpose was to,
was to,
um,
the extremist about climate change.
And I,
I came to believe that the whole thing
was,
um,
was a crock of shit and I left
quit.
Do you think that what happened?
I mean,
I
know very,
very,
very little on this.
I'm just gonna just take this at face
value and just debate you and not in
debate.
You just ask you questions.
Yeah.
Do you think that what is happening is
that an industry has been created?
Uh,
and that certainly is true that there is
an industry,
I'm not going to suggest that the whole
climate change establishment as a result
of some people rent seeking where there
is some of that going on,
but there is definitely a climate change
industry.
There's no doubt about it.
Right.
And it also is one,
it's something that if you,
it's like saying that you don't believe
in vaccines.
No,
I don't think it's the same.
You look,
but,
um,
but it is to public opinion.
No,
I don't think that's true.
I think,
I don't think so.
Opinion.
Well,
you never hear about it because the
media will never dare tell you a bit
more skeptical about many of the same
people who don't believe in climate
change also.
Anti-Vaxxers right.
But I don't think these two things have
anything in common.
And one of them is right.
One them is wrong.
Um,
you know which one's wrong?
Anti-Vaxxers right.
Or rule should vaccinate their children.
Right?
And climate changes bunk.
Um,
but if you need to say that,
you don't need to believe in climate
change,
a lot of times the same sort of
believing Wacko.
I don't care what they bought,
lump me in with.
I care about facts not being,
you know,
not whether somebody lumps me in with
the wrong group of people.
I've never cared about that.
I don't care what people think about me.
I care whether,
whether my argument is sounded,
whether I'm right or whether I'm funny
and entertaining people like me.
But,
um,
I don't care if somebody,
you know,
but people are people,
right?
Guys like us off all the time.
Right?
They said,
write me,
I was in Miss [inaudible] self-loathing,
homosexuals you did.
You did today on wrongly,
you know people do this all the time and
it's just another way that the left has
of dealers utilizing the speaker because
they don't like the arguments.
Rather than take the argument you called
the speaker self-loathing rather than
take the argument you call the speaker,
you know a bigger to have some other
kind,
you know what,
what all you pathologize you say that if
you're a gay person with these opinions
you must either have like some
psychological problem and you get for
you need therapy or you hate yourself
and your self loathing because of your
religious upbringing or the rest of it.
You don't allow that person the dignity
of having opinions that don't correspond
with their sexuality.
That I think is cheap and it ignores the
messy and complicated reality of human
sexuality and who people are.
I don't care if somebody thinks that I'm
a self loathing homosexual.
What I care about is,
is telling the truth that other people
seem to be reluctant to do gay people,
the gay establishment and uh,
you know,
certainly doesn't tell the truth about a
lot of things.
They don't tell the truth about born
this way.
They don't tell the truth about HIV.
They get very upset when you dare to
told,
you know,
I wrote this column like you know,
gay people,
if you want to start donating blood,
cause most gay people,
gay people are banned from donating
blood,
you know,
or at least it's very difficult in the
UK and I think the u s too,
and I wrote this column,
so if you want it to gay people are
complaining that they're not allowed to
donate blood and they said that it's,
you know,
evidence of homophobia,
whatever.
I said if you,
if you don't,
if you want to be able to donate,
blood stopped being sluts.
The reason that the,
the reason the NHS doesn't let you
donate blood,
it's because gay blood is so
disproportionately more likely to have
diseases in it.
If you want,
if you want to be allowed to donate
blood,
stop sleeping around and this kind of
stuff,
stop sleeping around just so they can
give other people,
it's not,
but that wasn't the point.
My point was to,
you know,
to get it,
the,
the whiners,
the winches and the social justice
warriors and handling it.
My point is I don't care if somebody
says,
you know,
you're still floating homosexual.
I know,
which isn't true.
It's a cheap debate tactic.
Um,
and it hasn't really has no meaning
outside of the fact that the argument.
Um,
so I didn't care about being lumped in
with,
with crazy people.
If my arguments are sound about a
particular issue,
I'd rather it wasn't.
But you know,
Auntie Auntie,
if you say to me,
will you come and you say,
I didn't believe in climate change.
And in my head I think,
Oh God,
you're like,
it can get crazy info wars conspiracy
theorist.
You're an Alex Jones type,
right?
Who probably thinks vaccines are a
conspiracy by the government.
Um,
I find that absurd.
And in any case,
I don't really mind too much because I
think,
I think ordinary people,
I think many of your fans and certainly
mine are a bit tired of having labels
applied to them by other people.
I think people are a bit tired of being
told what they are that told their
bigoted,
told them a sergeant stick,
told the um,
you know,
that there is something else wrong with
them or that they have the wrong
opinions about things.
I think people are a bit sick of that
actually.
Um,
and
uh,
indeed,
um,
you know,
I think people are a bit bored of that.
So I'm very relaxed about people calling
me names because I've had it my whole
career and normally it's a consequence
of telling the truth.
Got It.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of articles.
It's really interesting because I
googled it while you were talking about
the,
you know,
there's a quote that gets bandied around
a lot,
a 97% of climate scientists agree.
And,
uh,
there's a lot of fucking articles it
says that's horse shit.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's ever been true.
I think the 97,
I think that 97% of climate scientists
agreeing on climate change is in the
same category of,
um,
of immortal myth that the campus rape
culture,
statistically,
it's one of those sort of unquestioned,
it's like a,
it's become a,
a fact meme,
you know?
Uh,
it's one of those things as uncritically
reported and it's been repeated so many
times that people don't even feel the
need to us for a citation anymore.
And so for example,
when you hear this stuff about the rape
rape statistics or the pay gap,
people take it,
it's such an established part of
accepted a statistic.
Now people's have stopped bothering to
ask for evidence to justify it.
I don't think it was ever true.
Then.
I just 7% well,
you would know probably better than a
lot because you were actually there on
the front lines and you watched people
actually fuck with evidence and omit
things and add things and,
well,
what,
what was the,
when,
when you were there,
and this was all going on,
like what was the philosophy behind
politics?
It's all politics.
Climate change has never been about
science.
It's always a bit about politics.
Um,
you know,
and this is,
this is,
this is when right wing or sometimes
sound a bit conspiratorial,
a bit crazy,
right?
Won't miss it.
Oh,
it's all construction.
The liberal.
So 97% of scientist is a construction of
liberals.
Just guests get out.
Right.
I understand how that conversational
moment comes to happen,
but my more I can tell you is that it
was climate change for me as an
observer.
Lu for the scientists concern,
it was primarily a political project.
It was a lot to do with the,
the sort of UN global guilt about
poverty and the third world climate
change was this issue.
We're going to fix everything,
right?
It was going to fix poverty in third
world.
Uh,
you know,
it's finally addressed the sort of white
guilt.
They all feel and gave them all a real
reason to feel bad about being who they
are.
Um,
you know,
it gave them that,
uh,
that sort of terrible,
um,
you know,
you get it gave them the justification
to beat up on capitalism,
which they all hate,
gave them a justification to beat up on,
you know,
a western way of life.
And my James Delingpole,
my Breitbach colleague wrote a book
about watermelons green on the outside,
red on the red on the inside.
And his point was that his thesis is
that,
you know,
dressed up in the language of
environmentalism and climate change
concern is actually just socialism,
you know,
anti-capitalism uh,
it's sort of this,
this weird,
an archaic,
um,
desire to see cds.
The
developed world burn on the part of very
politicized scientist.
And I have to say,
based on what I saw,
he's right.
Well,
it still seems like it's a very high
number when they're breaking down.
Um,
there's a skeptical science article
about it and they break down the actual
number of scientists that do believe
that we have something to do with global
warming.
I mean,
ultimately this is a large number,
but ultimately the debate pointless
anyway.
You know,
most of,
you know,
there,
there are a million,
well,
top point is,
but it's,
there are millions of us
was about climate change and the,
and with one Google search,
you can't hope to get anywhere even
close to the truth.
But um,
in any case,
it's a good idea to get off fossil fuels
simply because going to run out,
it's a question of energy security,
not conservation.
For me,
I think for many conservatives who agree
that we have to find other solutions,
whether it's wind or nuclear or
something else,
right?
Um,
just drilling and using up all the oil
is going to,
I mean,
it's going to run out eventually,
right?
It's going to run out.
So we need to better select,
we need something else in the wings that
can take over.
That's,
that's not a question of ecology.
And that's not a political question
either.
It's just basic energy security,
making sure that we all have what we
need to survive and that we can all keep
our lights on.
Right.
Um,
so for me it's not,
you know,
there is a heavily politicized and I
think primarily political and not
scientific issue,
but um,
we should in any case,
be pursuing renewable energy because one
day we're going to have to,
even with shale gas,
which is going to fix us for another 100
200 years or something,
you know,
it's going to run out eventually and we
are going to be around when it does.
I believe that,
I always find it very disturbing when
people bring up this whole fracking
thing and they're very dismissive of it.
That that one freaks me out because
there's absolute evidence that they've
poisoned a lot of wells and there's
areas that people can't live in anymore,
that it's leaked into river supplies.
There's absolute evidence of that.
And then people like,
well,
the bill,
look how cheap the gas is now.
I'm like,
it doesn't matter if you fuck something
up to the point where it's useless a
hundred thousand years from now,
it doesn't matter.
The poisoned to river,
it doesn't,
I mean you made it,
supports it.
The EPA,
EPA would say that doesn't mean there
shouldn't be any EPA just because they
fucked up and poisoned the river.
Right.
Just because one fracking well fucked up
or even three,
four time fracking or 10 out of a
thousand a thousand maybe there needs to
be better at betting regulation.
Maybe they need to do they think maybe
they need to do it differently?
I guess the fracking,
I have idea actually more than a
million.
I've been totally out of that climate.
Energy stuff years.
Yes.
Right now I'm going to say friendly in
wells and 100,000 how many million?
Well,
fracking worlds.
You're kidding,
right?
In America?
No,
a million fracking host in America.
That's insane.
Yeah.
In America they call it possibly be.
I think it's more than that actually.
1.1 million active tus.
Yup.
I'm stunned,
but don't understand how my country
roles.
So in that case,
you could,
I mean,
you could present hundreds of examples
of poisoned rivers.
It will still be set,
but it still will be significantly
insignificant because [inaudible] still
needs that need to get in.
If there's 1.1 million of these wells
and you're only,
you could,
and there were a hundred scare stories
in the media every year.
That hundred is a relatively small
number if you're looking at statistics.
But if you're the actual human beings
that live anywhere near the nuclear
power,
you could say people die in nuclear
accidents.
So let's don't have
the kind of people do.
But they were even that many nuclear
actually didn't even a,
well,
they're are traction.
There are nuclear accidents in Japan are
Unisex since,
you know,
in,
in Russia.
Um,
well there's two and three mile island.
Right,
which is,
well,
probably comparable,
comparable,
comparable in numbers of people affected
to your fracking thing.
No,
we don't live in a perfect world.
We have to make a risk assessment and a
judgment and also price comes into it.
You know the cost and the amount of the
benefit to society of getting all of
this natural gas right?
If a couple of rivers of poisons,
we may say that that is the best of a
bad set of solutions right now.
None of this stuff is perfect because we
don't live in mud huts.
We want Nice Shit.
You know,
you want your cameras,
you want the Internet,
you won't computers.
You want to read a producer with seven
buzzing devices next to him that comes
at a price,
right?
There's an energy cost to that.
And if you want that,
you're going to have to get it from,
you're going to have to get the power
from somewhere and none of those
solutions are going to be,
things are going to like,
it's either drilling for it's Middle
East oil.
Well,
sure.
I think we should invade.
As Ann Coulter said in the country's
killed their leaders,
convert them to Christianity,
which she also said,
well,
she also said,
who is he?
And coulters.
So did you say he also said,
no,
I didn't.
I said,
she also said we should invade their
country's killed the leads and convert
them to Christianity.
He became a man.
What if she became a trainee and see the
ankle to whatever,
become a man.
She's a beautiful woman.
How dare you lie to the Ma America,
the world?
I can't imagine you are a right wing
shill.
You Saddleback church.
We really are supportive of fracking.
You love circumcision.
I love ankles.
Um,
I think she's tremendous.
I know I do.
And do you know what I do?
She falls into the same bucket you do.
And I do.
And Trump does.
She is.
No,
she's not troll.
You could characterize,
you could characterize much of what both
of us do is just trolling.
I don't trust them.
I don't tell me what I do with trolling.
Go ahead.
Viewers will make up their own judgments
on that one.
I'm not a tome fine.
Okay.
If you're not a trial,
that's fine.
I may say inflammatory things,
but I believe them.
I don't mean to meet you.
So where do I go?
[inaudible] shit about Mexicans.
I don't think she believes that I am.
I wanted to persuade you,
Kipp,
which is closest thing we have to
equipment,
the tea party.
I want to persuade Ukip in the UK who
were banned from the pride march because
of course the leftists,
Houma,
homosexual establishment are nothing,
if not a ruthlessly intolerance of
conservatives.
It was much more difficult for me to
come out as a Tory that it wasn't a gay
person.
Um,
uh,
Tory being a conservative and much more
just got to come out of the
Conservatives.
Is that then it must have been gay.
Um,
right wing,
like I said,
write me.
It's very difficult.
Uh,
I wanted Ukip,
who's,
I could look at the tea party to,
um,
to,
uh,
go all dressed in drag as Margaret
Thatcher and have signed,
we'll have signs,
things like,
um,
I've lost my thread.
Uh,
I lost my to say we've been talking for
a very long time.
Um,
what were you talking about?
gay people.
I've lost it.
Let's go to the UK and I've lost it.
It's gone.
It doesn't matter.
Trolling.
But now I've got,
I've got,
I've got a troll.
It's gone.
It's done.
You were accusing me of trolling,
it can be trollish as quarter.
Ken,
as Donald Trump is,
um,
where I think we can all be trollish and
it's it being provocative and outrageous
saying things you believe in.
Um,
the,
the definition of trolling is expanded
to cover that.
Now it's become essentially meaningless
word like racist.
Well,
it's also dismissal word.
It's like,
you know,
when someone calls you a sexist or
someone calls you a bigot,
they'll call you.
And I think what we all do,
all four of us,
is we say thing,
we gin up our jokes and our rhetoric and
our provocation to get attention and to
draw attention perhaps to people who are
unnecessarily offended by things that
they shouldn't be offended by two
idiots.
But in the course of doing so,
we do tell the truth what we really
believe in.
Now,
you may be the sort of least on that
spectrum that probably starts with you
and ends with Trump.
Your probably,
you know,
the least trollish but you still do it.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Well,
I think it's part of the countercultural
spectrum.
You know,
if people,
you know,
you're not part of a right wing
establishment media,
you're your own thing.
You are,
you know,
you fall,
um,
I think very squarely into that category
we talked about earlier.
You know,
that sort of,
I think many of the people who like each
of us,
uh,
have the same,
you know,
that we have,
we have a big overlap I think of,
of,
of our listeners and fence.
Yeah.
So I think we do too.
I'm trollish in some,
here's one like what I said earlier
about tweeting about male feminists
choking to death on Vegan.
Peter.
That's clearly true but offensive.
It just strikes me,
it strikes me as good government policy.
Um,
we just did three hours,
man.
Shit.
Really?
That was it.
And we could have done another three
easily when going to come to blows once
on the gay stuff.
That's what's fun.
It's fun when people die.
We got more heated about Christianity
than anything.
Yes we did.
Because you're a militant atheist.
Refused to extend that even an easy,
except the obvious truth that your your,
here's the thing,
this is where people can't get wrong.
Get me wrong.
I am not an economist.
I'm not,
I don't even,
I wouldn't even class.
And you know what,
as anti I'm just,
I don't believe people,
I think people are full of shit.
And when I read a story that's full of
Shit,
like look at,
first of all,
I know too much about the construction
of the Bible.
I know too much about the new testament.
I know Constantine and a bunch of
bishops constructed it and decided what
to leave out.
I know Constantine didn't even become a
Christian until right before he fucking
died.
Okay.
I know that the original Bible was
written in ancient Hebrew and to this
day there's a fucking shit ton of words
in ancient Hebrew that they have no idea
what the hell they mean.
Not only that,
they an ancient Hebrew letters double as
numbers.
There were no numbers.
So the letter a was also the number one,
there's a numerical value to words and
sentences that was completely lost in
the translation to Latin and Greek and
eventually English.
I know that you're a well read and
passionate on the subject,
so let's move on.
We can't move on.
It's,
I'm not even,
I'm not anti God.
I've had so much flat a great,
it's been great.
Thank you for having me on man time ever
in town again.
Let's do it again.
We could probably be,
you can be sure.
I'll be back.
Uh,
I think that's my next sentence then we
could do what?
I really like it guest,
we can do 180.
I've had a lovely time.
And when you come to London,
um,
make sure you let me know and I'll say
absolutely.
I'm usually in London like once a year.
Um,
how often do you mean house Angeles?
I think I'm going to be around a lot
more now.
Someone's got something cooking,
which I can't quite tell you that I have
a little,
I have a little announcement coming in
the next seven days,
which,
um,
uh,
will draw me to the u s much more often.
Well,
listen,
you're a lot of fun.
Your articles are fantastic.
I really enjoy it.
Your Twitter feeds great.
Check it out.
It's Nero,
the one that killed all the Christians
that is evil,
that evil.
Do that.
So regulations are getting that as a
Twitter handle.
That's an excellent friends in low
places.
Excellent catch.
All right.
That's it ladies and gentlemen.
We'll be back tomorrow until then.
Go Fuck Yourself.
So I ride up by,
yes.